absolutely
good morning
um
first action for the day
and I'm is that 577
so welcome
um been delayed a little bit with uh
getting some of our uh normal paperwork
that we need for hearings and exec
sessions but uh I think we're ready for
the hearing on uh House Bill 654 which
is relative to the one-year certificate
certificate of teaching eligibility and
uh call on uh representative layout to
present the Bill thank you very much uh
representative cardelli and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Rick Ladd I come from Haverhill New
Hampshire uh that's graphed in five uh
we have a number of communities which
are in that number five now landath
Piermont Warren Pier um
Benton Haverhill I think I got them
um what we have here performs today is
654 is a bill relative to the one-year
certification of teacher teaching
eligibility
and the reason why this bill is before
you it went before the
the committee which we have here for
allowing late legislation to come
forward
and it's late legislation that came in
due to the fact that we have another
committee that's very active and we need
to even gear it up seeing we lost our
our chairman and now we have to have
another chairman for the teacher
shortage committee identified and it's a
Senate bill so the Senate has to
identify the chairman or for identify
the people are going to be on it so at
any rate this bill is one where we're
trying to look at the situation which we
have with the teacher shortage which is
a very real situation in our state
especially in the areas of Science in
mathematics and special education and
within science you can also Link in
technical support or technical uh
aspects of teaching and in support so
what are we going to do to try to get
past this and and support getting more
people into the field of education so
this is just one just one of the options
which we have available to rectify this
teacher shortage or to support us in in
getting somebody in the classroom that
has certification that may be a little
bit different certification than the
certification which we would normally
have for a chemistry teacher in the high
school
and so I'd like to explain uh how this
works
we may have a shortage in in school
district Y and it might be a science
teacher and yet they can't find somebody
with the credential or the certification
in that specific area it's a very
specific area of instruction which you
need to have that background information
and and so but we have another way of
doing it when you get to the front door
School the two days before school starts
and there's not a teacher available for
chemistry what do you do
so this legislation that we're talking
about this area of Statute 189 39b was
put into place a number of years ago so
that we could
hire a person that had a bachelor's
degree
had a criminal background check and that
came out fine and had some understanding
and experience or understanding of the
of the subject of chemistry so that that
person could get the local
superintendent can do this
but the limit of time is just one year
and so you have a one-year
certification to do this
what this bill also does is that even in
the one year it also says this teacher
this person is certified must be held
accountable to the professional code of
ethics and professional code of conduct
um
this is put in there just so it's
understood I believe that when it comes
right down to the rulemaking authority
of the Department of Education which is
already establishes that I think we
already have it but this identifies it
and there shouldn't be any concerns now
in that regard every teacher must comply
with that code and I think that's
supported by Administration and staff
and teachers within the building as well
but getting back to the top part of this
there this one year is one where a
person may be identified we may identify
there's a shortage and they come in
let's say in November
that one-year ticket is good for one
year November to November
oftentimes that then extends into the
next school year and they have somebody
that's done an excellent job and has
said I really want to become a teacher
in this system I have now gotten into a
course either at one of the four years
to get the credential done properly but
you and I know that you can't do this in
one short year or even a half a year
after they get in the class and make
decision I want to go on so this
one-year extension allows that
individual to do that it also affords
the opportunity that you don't have as
much change going into the classroom uh
when you have somebody really is doing
the job for you as an administrator I
would say well I'd like to be able to
keep this person although I want to
ensure that the basic standards that we
have for certification are applied to
this Pathway to certification
I've also received and you have in front
of you a this communication came to us
just yesterday from
Steve Appleby from doe behind us and
there's some changes there which I'm
going to let him speak to where this the
way the legislation's written right now
it says teaching educator we have some
other certified people they're not
necessarily teaching they could be
supporting in technical support excuse
me representative um are there copies of
what you're referring to
um yeah I've seen copies on both sides
they're supposed to be coming down
is that copy just the amended version
that you see you passed around not your
testimony this is draft language it's
not an amendment we haven't gotten the
amendment back from OLS but this is the
draft that I got from the DOE
okay last night this is done okay here
we go
so there should be copies out there for
everybody
okay rather than my taking you through
this I'm going to have director Appleby
do that these are some changes that
they're seeing that if we add these
changes it it's going to really support
those people in some schools that really
need to be able to do this they're going
to have the the wherewithal the
statutory language behind them to do it
so I'd be glad to take any questions
from the committee at this time
please leave any questions to this one
to the department which is going to
follow
thank you representative miler thank you
Mr chair
um I think also you uh representative
lad you mentioned the content area
problems but also in the isn't it true
that in the teacher shortage uh
committee we also identified problems of
rural school districts retaining
teachers as well as underperforming
schools retaining teachers and that was
also part of the conversation above and
beyond just the content areas that you
mentioned yes and I had we had one other
area representative Miler yes rural
location is an issue underperforming is
an issue but poverty is also an issue
there's a direct relationship between
the level of poverty in the community
and the achievement of students and so
and
you and I know that if I were looking
for a job I would certainly look for a
job which is going to pay ten thousand
dollars more per year than the one that
may be local so rather than working in
Haverhill I try to trip down and get a
job in Lebanon or Hanover
and that's happening in my district and
I know it's happening all over the state
so there are three areas and these are
three critical areas that must be
addressed and this is just one of many
of the ideas that come out of the
teacher shortage committee and that's an
active committee still working towards
trying to develop some resolution to
when we encountered this in future years
we have a methodology to try to address
it and also to ensure the pool of people
with certification is there for us in
this state we lose a lot of our folks
out of state
further questions representative Tanner
so um
has any uh effort been made to look at
uh or to ask these people that are on
these one or two year uh teaching
certificate
uh to go licenses
um to actually be
trying to get certification to actually
be in the process of trying to get
certification through some of the other
methods that you can get certification
yes and I that's ongoing and you notice
that there's while you may have received
an email from the Department just the
other evening I don't know if everybody
got it where if you average out the
number of of folks that are attempting
to get this resolved through this
one-year teacher certification spout 140
people a year roughly 100 to 150 in that
neighborhood out of the total number of
certification which we have in the State
000 so we're talking really a small
number over top but this is just another
tool in the toolbox for the school
district to open the doors with somebody
in the classroom that has expertise in
the area we're looking for
a representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you thank you very much representative
Vlad
um this may be maybe it's a question for
you maybe it's a question for Mr Appleby
when
um uh from the Department on on this but
of the 150-ish
employed under this under the existing
statute are are those
um and and I know nope what what you
handed out refers it makes some other
um there's some other language changes
in here referring to them as Educators
not teachers which which makes and I
think you I ought to vacate that
question too okay yeah no that's
director I think that he has a knowledge
what's going on and he's working very
closely with several districts right now
in and trying to help them out have the
people in place so and that's a good
question I think I know where you're
going no I'm happy to I'm having to take
that up at the same thanks
representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair and thank you for my
question representative
um
my concern is to make sure there's
safeguards here so this doesn't become
the practice the standard practice
because I fear that we're going to start
I mean I I think that we need that
second year of Eligibility without a
doubt you go north of the Notch and buy
any newspaper there's a zillion jobs you
could walk into today if you were
licensed I just don't want it to be
an acceptable practice for a person to
start with a two-year
and now we're making exceptions because
they're there three years four years and
what quality are we providing to the
kids so I would want some safeguards and
maybe the code of ethics or the code of
conduct is gonna
or some checks and balances on whether
they are moving through a program uh UNH
is great about their teacher rule
program produces great teachers off-site
there's another North Country teacher
program I mean these are resources that
I would suspect
school districts all over the state have
um in some fashion so somebody needs to
Mentor that candidate to make sure
they're working towards a teacher degree
if that is their chosen pathway I think
that's a good question and I I believe
that Mr can really help you out with
that but one other part of this you
can't just go for a certification like
this for one year and then two years
later that person comes in with no this
is worded so it has to be consecutive at
abutting the year that you issued the
first one in okay following that so that
is putting a little control on it and I
agree with you I'm I'm I see this as
just an emergency route which we can
take and I believe when I talked with
the superintendents this last Monday at
the conference over at Grappone they
they see this as just that that they
want to have somebody in with the CR the
certification in the ways now I'm not
talking CTE because CTE is a totally
different ball game here so um they
understand this I don't don't truthfully
I haven't seen any real abuse on that I
think most your administrator
superintendents are aware of this they
try to get somebody it's just like well
this is a CTE situation where Chris
Dodge had down in Salem and person hired
three days before took off for a job
that doubled his salary elsewhere in
Kansas or in the midwest you know he it
was a tech type oriented position and
going from that at the max at Chris
Dodge could the director of CT and Salem
could offer was right around seventy
thousand dollars a person went out and
doubled the salary
follow-up please
um
is there any thought about maybe these
this candidate taking the Praxis one as
all teacher candidates need after
semester two I believe are required to
take a basic skills
test before they go on into the prep
program or would you ask that question
too I will yes that this is Steve's
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question there are actually two
um I'm wondering if and I appreciate the
numbers currently our small 142 150. but
I'm wondering if there's any
statement made about how many people
teaching through this credential a
particular system could have at the same
time
are you saying that you might have an
elementary teacher that wants to teach
in the high school and doesn't have a
credential for high school no I'm sorry
I wasn't clear
I'm saying what percentage of teaching
staff in a particular School
at one point in time could be teaching
in this way I think experience would it
would come from Steve Appleby on that I
I don't have I I don't want to guess at
that
I just want to clarify the meaning of
line 24
is that saying that a particular
individual can only do this once in one
District or is it saying something else
this is controlled by Department of
Education they don't care where you are
in what school it's once one time only
and this that's a requirement for this
we have different alternative Pathways
towards certification this is one of
those
and it's controlled by Doe very closely
represent painter
um I actually got into a little
discussion with some people up in my
area I think it was that earlier this
summer and uh on this subject and they
were uh trying to see if there was they
were talking about retired teachers
bringing retired teachers back and
whether there was going to be an
incentive for them to do it because
right now it's a disincentive
um as far as the retirement uh system
you know is set up and that sort of
thing and has any was any discussion
made about bringing retired teachers
back in there has been a lot of
discussion I see representative going
yeah like that on the teacher shortage
committee we've talked about retirement
we've had the retirement folks in to
explain how that system works so how
many hours that a retired employee is
allowed to work in the classroom that's
something that I know uh Steve Appley is
very aware of how many hours is that
about 30 hours per
29.5 I was 0.5 off that there are
allowed to teach over the course of the
year and of course that's to if you're
retired we are looking at that we know
there's a lot of retired teachers out
there that are you know maybe interested
in in coming back and helping out in a
shortage or it will just retire too
early and they're saying I want to get
back in the game and and so but they're
also collecting retirement at the same
time then you start talking about
benefits and all that other from the
state and what they're going to get at
the system we've had that same issue
with municipal government and when it
comes to Corrections some of the retires
as a state trooper wants to come back
and work as a corrections officer
retirement is always something that's
got to be considered this one has to be
considered and it is possible that you
could do that but you're you have a
limitless how much you can work so an
average day what's five five and a half
hours of teaching multiply that times
five you come underneath that 29.5 so
you can do that
follow up
um so I one of the concerns was that
um you know by the time you retire
sometimes you have multiple
certifications in multiple different
subjects
um and
if you retire and say you know you don't
let you don't renew your certification
um did they discuss it all about we've
discussed that on that committee as well
yeah a lot of people let that lapse and
then you know any further questions for
representative Vlad I've seen none thank
you very much and we'll call uh Stephen
good morning representatives for the
record Stephen Appleby from Auburn New
Hampshire I am the director of educator
support and higher education at the
so
um I'll make a couple of points and then
I'll answer questions I think
um some some pieces and I'll try and
address some of what I was hearing for
representative Ladd
um
we ran some numbers which I shared with
representative lad which I think he can
disseminate but over the last five years
um we have issued beginning in the
2018-2019 uh year we issued 85 the
following year 1920 we issued 83 uh 2021
the first year of the pandemic we issued
2021-2022 we issued 152 and this year to
date we've issued 136 of these it's
important to note that once an
individual currently in the current
system is issued one of these one-year
certificates they can never get another
one it goes into our licensure system
and if they try and go to another
District in a couple of years and that
District asks us for one we have to
inform that District that they've
already used that one in the previous
year so they can't skip a couple of
years and come back it's a one-time only
per person
as it stands today forever
so
um and with the wording in the bill this
would extend it to a second consecutive
year within the district they're already
in
and as as representative Ladd mentioned
sometimes folks are hired mid-year this
is often used as well
um when they have an unexpected
long-term absence from an educator so
for example I was speaking yesterday
with Hollis Brookline they had an
educator go out on leave long-term
medical leave in the fall they utilized
the one-year certificate to bring
someone into cover
they really like the individual
but that individual doesn't qualify yet
for a statement of Eligibility which
puts them on the site-based pathway uh
where they go on an intern license
essentially
um but they really like the individual
and they want to do a second year
because lo and behold this teacher is
going to be out it looks like again and
they would like to keep that consistency
and keep that individual and they will
use that second year to get them
converted over to the intern
authorization process
so
um that's typically the pathway for
districts they bring someone in because
there's an emergency and if they like
that individual they then help them get
qualified for an intern authorization
and they start on that alternative
pathway
um to full licensure so
um questions I'm representative luno so
thank you very much Mr chair thanks very
much Steve for uh for joining us this
morning and being able to take some uh
technical questions on this when you
were just referring to we issued what
what were you talking about so
um there are administrative rules which
instruct the Bureau of credentialing to
process the school board has to notify
the department and we take that
notification and process a one-year
certificate we called emergency
authorization an administrative rule but
and then we track that oh okay yeah and
a follow-up on that so so the way the
current law seems to read to me is that
the local school board
um
um uh issues the Certificate of
Eligibility and then just for
clarification that well it says in the
statute they notify the department then
the Department issues a we call it an
emergency authorization emergency and
that's our way of tracking it and
complying okay and then and then and so
that was really sort of clarification
the follow-up is um is really for the
for the second year
um under the current law
um could could somebody
um uh could a person who's who's
employed under the emergency
authorization
request a um uh what is it what is it
called in the doe and ALT
um oh a statement of Eligibility yeah
yeah could they operate for a second
year they under under alt without
changing the law
so the the issue uh they could but they
would have to meet now the requirements
of whatever endorsement that they're
pursuing the entry level requirements so
um and in order if they
um sort by backup uh the alternative
Pathways that used to be called We Now
call it site-based licensing program
um those individuals applied to the
department for what's called a statement
of Eligibility to the Bureau of
credentialing and we review their
qualifications typically academic
history have they taken Praxis core to
show basic academic skills we review all
of those and if they meet those for the
given endorsement let's say chemistry
teacher we issue them what's called a
statement of Eligibility they then take
that statement of Eligibility and they
go to districts and they interview and
if a district says we want to hire you
the district then contacts the
department on their behalf to seek an
intern authorization
and the district files what we call the
beginning of plan which is their
development plan and that can that plan
can be one year in length to meet the
requirements or it can be up to three
years in length most individuals it
takes them a year to two years very few
you know some go three years but many
it's it's uh one to two years so
um the the one-year Certificate of
Eligibility is is almost a Runway if you
will towards that
um and because sometimes some of the
endorsements may require 10 classes in
that subject area and that individual
may not have them right
um
so that that this gives the district
time again to you know try before we buy
do we do we think this individual is a
fit and has the quality you know the the
skills the disposition to be an educator
and then
um they can say okay now we're going to
keep them the the other issue that that
comes up and again I was talking to hola
Sportline yesterday and they were
talking about you know when a teacher or
an educator unexpectedly goes out on
leave and then they come back
but maybe they relapse or they have some
other medical and they go back out
and so we had someone on a one year they
came in they covered
that one year expires over the summer
that educator comes back and three weeks
into school they leave again
they want to reach back out to that
person
and perhaps now keep them but you know
the giving them the extra year
um the district was very much in favor
of because they feel that it gives them
flexibility okay great thank you very
much for the questions from the
committee representative Tanner
thank you I whenever I am involved in
the discussion of certified teachers
versus non-certified teachers
I'm I've flashed back to several
instances and and they're rare but they
were instances where people didn't have
the temperament to teach came in on a
one-year certificate and something you
know they blew up at a kid or even maybe
assaulted a kid
um and you know if you're certified and
you've gone through teacher training not
only do you learn the you know how to
handle adolescents and some psychology
and you learn teaching methods and you
are also screened during your student
teaching for temperament and and you
learn the laws of the regulate
um you know teaching in in the public
schools and over the years when we've
talked about sex education and and I was
a health teacher so I had that field uh
in my toolbox and
outrageous things happened I had to say
that it was probably somebody that
didn't have the training that I had and
so I really value that that training
that a certified teacher has the process
that they go through I also worked with
the Department a couple times on
alternative licensing and didn't feel in
in several cases that
what we prescribed was adequate to
prepare somebody for for actually being
in the classroom
I take
um representative cascadden's remarks
very much to heart that I think that
they should be uh involved with some
program where there's mentoring
um and that I I hope that and you know
and to leave it up to the school I don't
know if that's because superintendents
and principals are so overburdened but
you know to have a mentor in in the
school uh that's actually monitoring
things to to kind of short-circuit any
kind of
things that are going to blow up
um and I'm wondering if I guess my
question is
do you feel
can you
um
do you feel that my concerns are being
met in in doing this uh Bill the way it
is and allowing that second year of of
you know
I'm trying to just make sure I get to
the core of what you are mentioning you
know so I've been at the department for
five years and I have we have not had a
misconduct issue involving an individual
on a one-year certificate in the five
years I've been there
um we've had misconduct issues of course
with licensed Educators we've had
misconduct issues with Educators who are
um going work on an intern authorization
but we have not had one to my knowledge
for someone on a one year
um
I'm wondering if that would come rise to
your level that uh you know that if
they're on a one-year certificate or
just brand new kind of in the first day
I we've had people come in and walk out
in the first day you know I mean
so I just right they have no idea what
it's like facing 30 high school kids or
Elementary you know first graders right
so I would just say from from a
geographic standpoint our investigator
um we you know speak daily about
I
I would know yeah I'm pretty confident
that I would know if they were on that
um
so and I think it's important
um to note that again we have 28 000
individuals that hold a license
Statewide from the Department of
Education of that 28 000 uh several
thousand hold what we call a license for
life that the department used to issue
or the State Board you stationed many
years ago they never expire but those
folks typically are retired by now so
and I see representative Heath shaking
your head
um she remembers those
um so if we say there's 25 to 26 000 now
that hold a license again several
thousand of those folks are not in New
Hampshire they're in other states maybe
they went to school here and they got
their license here and then they
relocated so now we're down to say let's
say 23 24
000 individuals well again some number
of those are administrators or not t not
working
so maybe there's eighteen thousand
seventeen thousand teachers I did reach
out to the Nea to see if they had some
numbers on teachers
um and and they were looking into that
but if we say 17 or 18 000 teachers
um you know Educators not administrators
but all of the support rules and and the
teachers then I think those numbers of
100 to 150 a year
are really really small and I know the
question came up earlier about in any
one District I think it's important to
note that we have 107 saus and about
500-ish public schools in our state K-12
and we're get you know issuing less than
a third of that number annually so
um there could be two in a particular
but I I think
um I I don't know the numbers for sure
but I would be surprised if there's more
than a couple in a particular SAU at any
time
so thank you representative miler
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here this morning
I've got three three quick questions how
many of these
individuals go on and seek a teaching
certificate
many many do many I don't have an exact
number but it's more often than not okay
uh set out second question is you use
the term in here educator
uh could you explain why you use that
term rather than like instructor or why
that particular term so we have made a
concerted effort over the last five
years to be consistent in our language
when describing positions historically
if you look at throughout the education
statutes
you know we even use the word the the
term superintendent very Loosely if you
go by Statute every school building in
our state is supposed to have a super
superintendent
um so we've been trying at least in the
Bureau of credentialing in my area to
clean up our language so that it it
statured and Rule match and it and it
says what we want it to say and it
doesn't just imply something so by my my
suggested Amendment to the chair
um by changing that to educator we now
not only cover just teachers but we
cover folks like digital learning
Specialists Librarians some of those
support roles that districts have have
also had trouble with
um so we at which sometimes as well have
very high bars to entry
one more and final question I'm assuming
that these individuals under this
certificate fall under the collective
bargaining agreement of the local school
district is that correct
I could not I do not know so that would
be an employment question so perhaps
um
thank you yeah thank you uh
representative cascadden thank you Mr
chair uh just double checking so a
candidate who's on a one-year emergency
waiver then goes through the
site-based plan technically has four
years to get their license as a teacher
well once they're on the site-based that
they've got three years so let's say
they're halfway through their one-year
certificate and they apply for an intern
authorization now it's time now it's
three years so so it could be three and
a half right and usually that comes at
the expense of that candidate so
whatever's on their plan they have to
take so many courses they have to do so
many field work so by going with this
additional year technically gives them a
five-year potential
if they're a good candidate which they
incur the cost so this buys them an
extra year I mean college courses aren't
cheap so I just want to double check
that that might be a path that would
entice people to work towards teacher
certification if they never could afford
it right I think okay I think that's
correct
any further questions uh representative
Damon
not sure if this is a question for you
or for the Bill's sponsor
but reflecting on both representative
cascadden and represented Tanner's
remarks and I wrote the word Mentor
right before you said it
could there be language in the revision
of the bill to require districts to
designate a particular mentor
for these individuals as opposed to just
generically saying that they will be
helped
yeah I I don't know if I could answer
I there could be
but I'm I'm not sure
um
what would be our mechanism to ensure
from I'm just thinking practically
because again in my world the Bureau of
credential where you know we if there's
a rule we have to have some way to make
sure it's followed
um
follow
I think it would be that the person
identified as the mentor in the school
would that would need to be communicated
to doe in that 30 day when they submit
we have this person who's coming into
the system in this way
um
I'm just concerned that obviously the
existing educator staff is extremely
busy
and people certainly intend to be
helpful but there's a difference between
generally having people you can find
somebody to ask a question of versus
having a mentoring relationship with
somebody
who is more closely connected to how
that one individual is progressing
and I particularly think it's important
because as I'm pretty sure we'd all
agree you can be very very knowledgeable
in a subject area and not be skilled at
teaching
uh anything any further questions
representative Heath
thank you and thank you for letting me
ask a question thank you Steve for being
here
um we have wonderful teacher education
facilities in our state they're fabulous
has any consideration been given to when
um an individual is is
um hired by a district that may be
um some kind of an arrangement could be
made with one of the existing teacher Ed
programs some kind of a contract or
something that they would oversee
because I agree teachers are overwhelmed
there's a lot going on in our Public
Schools but at the same time teaching is
hard and um either a mentor or
I think it would be preferable to have
someone from an academic institution be
working with the CTE would that be a
possibility that something could be
um considered to uh put that kind of a
thank you for the question
I don't see why not
um but but I also would say that there
are occasions they're less often but
there are occasions where a district may
use this and they use it for four months
because an individual is out for a short
period but longer than the substitute
rule allows and so maybe in that case
they wouldn't
sponsoring that person to go further so
thank you represent pedernal thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Appleby for
taking my question
I agree with mentoring I mean it can be
unbelievably helpful but I'm wondering
if a it's out of the scope of this law
and be whether or not that is something
that would be that we would prefer to
leave up to local control through the
superintendent or the principal to set
the
um parameters for how they run their
schools thank you thank you for the
question as I've been told many times I
don't have that much of an opinion that
anyone cares about so
um I I what I will say and answer is I
think the mentoring issue from what we
have seen what I have seen is a much
larger issue than this
we talked a little bit at the study
committee this past year about the
turnover of new teachers that 22 year
old who comes out of a program and they
put him in a classroom in September and
that you know we'll see in June and they
don't get support some districts I can
tell you Merrimack Valley School
District does a fantastic job with new
Educators they have a dedicated person
that's their only job but there are
other districts where it's pretty much
what I just said we'll see in June and
then we have high turnovers so I think
the mentoring piece is a larger and may
warrant some other
um other thoughts
so representative cascadden thank you is
it all right for me to address the
mentor
question
um
so I have um
overseeing many of these plans because I
feel it's the role of the superintendent
to monitor those people not every
District does I've been to a district
where the secretary monitored it and I
took it over immediately
um
but I can tell you from my training on
these anytime a person went on an
emergency waiver and then began a plan
the candidate was required to find a
mentor anywhere that was certified in
the field they were working on so I I
Mentor teachers in Littleton who are
getting certified as English speakers of
other languages because I'm certified in
that field and then you monitor I mean I
within the district you meet you should
meet with that candidate on an annual
basis to see how they're progressing
through their plan and to provide
resources but yes they should be a
mentor that knows that
um there are also districts who have
titled two funds we had a very extensive
um mentoring program so that we paid
stipends to teachers who wanted to be
mentors to new teachers within the
district
and again it's not consistent I'm sure
but it's a valuable tool as
representative Heath said so mentoring
does occur and it should occur to those
candidates so thank you thank you
um I think mentoring maybe is a separate
uh subject to address
um uh I mean it's uh
Standalone role but um
any further questions for Mr Appleby I
see none just comment one closing
comment
um chair lad just whispered in my ear
that there is a bill regarding mentoring
thank you all right thank you um
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Brian Hawkins representing Nea New
Hampshire today I'll I'll uh keep my
comments fairly brief a lot of the
questions we had about this bill were
addressed uh specifically some of the
questions that representative cascadden
and Tanner are raised with respect to
you know we want to put people into the
classroom we don't want to just put a
warm body there we want to make sure
that that person is you know especially
if they're interested in it or as
quickly as possible being put on a a a a
certification plan if that's if that's
what they want to do so uh so I guess my
point in raising that again is just that
we in looking at this that we're looking
at this as only one small piece of the
puzzle and not
um you know something that is going to
be helpful in in
the long term which I think is Let's uh
strengthen the pipeline of educators we
have coming into the profession
as Mr Appleby and representative Ladd
mentioned you know there are several
bills uh working their way through the
legislature and Senate on that
specifically on
um
mentoring there is a a bill that will
hopefully make its way over here having
to do with the state better supporting
mentoring programs for local school
districts I just wanted to also answer
the the question regarding uh position
positions in a in a collective uh you
know collective bargaining unit
so I think the short answer would be yes
if uh if if there is a covered position
that that person with the emergency
certificate is filling then they would
be in the bargaining unit
um so something like math math teachers
are in the bargaining unit I'm feeling a
math teacher position not in the bargain
unit so
um
thank you very much uh any questions
see none thank you very much
and um
yes representative lead
I want to tack onto what Brian was just
saying but going a little bit farther
it's responsibility in statute right now
where all certified people are evaluated
by Administration or by their supervisor
each year there's observations and
evaluation required now when you add
into that you know it the the people I
was uh evaluating and we I had to do so
many observations for every evaluation
and for a person that's in their first
year as three evaluations a year in my
district so that was our policy so that
holds up this uh nine observations that
are written down and communicated but
there's many you're in there every day
when I see somebody needing that help
immediately we start in with the
monitoring mentoring program and that's
written up as part of the observation
report the evaluation report and and I
hope we can tack on to what's going on
in the Senate right now because that
does result in needed funds to do that
one of the recommendations I went made
where it was that the person go back to
University main Farmington and take some
courses in language arts and if they
wanted to even you know continue the
year that they were in so I I think it's
incumbent Upon Our principles and maybe
it's the director of special education
that's doing the supervision of the you
know the uh the life skills teacher to
to make sure they're in that classroom
also unfortunately we lay down a lot of
paperwork for them and regulations and
it keeps them out of the class oh thank
you very much
um with that I'll close the hearing on
House Bill 654 and I think we are next
scheduled for executive session
um was there some request for a break
yes so we will uh break for a caucus
foreign
Yeah
well moving forward right here uh I'd
like to welcome everybody back we are
now the education committee is going to
go into executive session we have a
number of bills set up for this this
late afternoon on late morning and
afternoon uh the first one on the the
docket right here is
um hb155
this is a bill relative excuse me
relative to the division of educator
support in higher education and relative
to Surety indemnification for private
post-secondary career schools
so I'd like to recognize representative
cordelli for a motion please
thank you Mr chairman on House Bill 155
I move ought to pass
represent Belcher seconds the motion
so we're into the last discussion on
this bill right now representative
cordelli thank you
um I'd like to discuss 155 along with
168 they're both overlap in terms of
Surety bonds
um
155 does also do a couple of things in
terms of membership of the division of
higher ed support in terms of
removing one member and
listing several others for the
possibility of designee in terms of the
surety bond we had discussion of of that
along with 168 which is a bill that I
had worked with
um Mr Appleby on and in further
discussions with that
um
he thought he actually liked the
language in 155 better than what we had
worked on in 168 in terms of uh the uh
10 percent of annual growth in the year
in which the of the current Academic
Year
um which is the language in 155.
so
um he he thought that was a better
language actually
um
I'm not sure where it came from but he
liked it better uh so
um you know our intention was to move a
155 and then I would
um i.tl my own bill 168.
further discussion from the second
none thank you for sure as rep Port
Ellie said this is a just a basic need
the department of vacation brought to us
to rather they prefer this bill over the
one they brought to us so
it was just get done
let's open up to uh further discussion
now from the committee members
representative miler uh thank you Mr
chair uh somebody answered the question
for me please why do we want to reduce
to 10 percent of the annual growth
what's the advantage of that
as we particularly look at trying to
protect students
in case something should happen
uh so why why do we want to do it why
I don't know who to direct that too but
uh if I might yes go ahead yeah
um I I think Mr Appleby had indicated
that he thought that that was a
reasonable based on the fact that there
have only been foreclosures in 20 plus
years to his knowledge
um and it would also help
new career schools uh get started
um without the overwhelming burden of a
higher surety bond and the charges for
such
um
but he felt that that was
adequate based on past history
Madam Clerk
the motion is
OTP on
hb155 relative to the division of
educator support in higher education and
relative Surety indemnification for
Vice chairman cordelli yes yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Myler no
representative Lane
no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Ellison no
representative woodcock
representative Heath nope representative
Balboni no Representative kaskadin no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 knees
foreign
we don't have to go you know we can just
leave it at
um at the
well there's no recommendation right now
absolutely no recommendation so that we
have left itl or retained
right
and then events going to be ought to
pass on the on the floor if it goes to
the whole unless unless routine
that's right oh
we have several options which we can do
here
um this is not an early bill
if we see there's some things which need
further work on it
you can retain one
and not take action on the second bill
here today which is very similar
and and because if you retain it it's
retained
and we can work on it but we would work
over on the up or the course of the
remainder of this year and then November
have to come up with a recommendation if
I could suggest that we we move forward
and what happens with 155 happens with
155.
that's basically what we're talking
about right now if we don't we have two
ways of moving forward with that bill
well I thought I thought oh you said Mr
chair was that um that we could retain
155 and then not exact 168.
um
that that would that would be the
process which if retain is the motion
which we support right right then I
would highly recommend that we keep you
know you know well then we could deal
whatever we wanted to if you wanted to
act on it this year
you know but prior to
June right then you would have to have
something to do it with and that would
have to be done with one six 168 and
amend 168. and then 168 the way we want
to do it if we we put down 168 and we
retain 155 we would then end up dealing
with it in November but um and and so
there's that's one track we go or we can
just leave it at you know right now
um if if we're wanting to
um
get to the floor with you know no
recommendation
um
is that you know no recommendation it's
gonna be one report there the way it is
right now
because there's no other you know
there's no idea if you want to go itl
then that would be a 10-10 then right
a move to retain and then hold on 168
and then move have more conversation
about both of these uh from a retained
sample
okay we yeah so go ahead yeah
in hoping we can get to a bipartisan uh
Solution on using 168.
okay so uh there is a motion put forward
by repson Miller for retaining this bill
is there a second
represent Damon seconds that
further discussion on the retaining
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
please Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal
yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yes
representative Lane yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes or representative cascadden
yes representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years one day
thank you very much so
um
based on our discussion I'm not even
going to bring 168 up to the floor right
now
and so we will discuss that uh we have
until March 16th to make a decision on
that particular bill
so just put that down in your locker or
something we put off that would be about
the fifth of the sixth bill which I've
done Mr chair on on 168
um I think that I think this is a good
process on this and maybe we could have
that that's sure that that's you know
I'm open to that yeah you can even put
together if we need a subcommittee to
work with him maybe by you know tripping
over there to work with him here so I'd
like to do that I'll put together a
subcommittee and that subcommittee can
go try to hammer this thing out I think
that's a great idea thanks again thanks
okay uh the next bill which we have on
the on the docket if we go down that way
is 170 we do not have that amending
language back yet so I'm going to jump
you have some discussion not Amendment
or not a motion
go ahead no
um
if you're going to have a subcommittee I
just want to offer could primex risk
management
organization be a resource in that
discussion with Mr Appleby just
I don't know yeah just offering that out
there because that's their specialty the
the technical support we use on and
subcommittees managed much differently
than we do for a regular hearing or what
we're doing here a subcommittee we
oftentimes do engage in the intent is to
get as much information as we can even
though they may not be a voting member
they're there for technical support and
they are really you know actively
involved in in the outcome so
um yes the answer is yes to that and and
any other you know organization agency
that has information that that
subcommittee wants to chase after that
has to be approved by the subcommittee
to open up and invite them to the table
to work with them
right
um so I'm going to jump over this next
one right here
um this is uh 170 we don't have all the
information back from OLS uh supposed to
have it
um Expediting it that we don't have it
so uh going down HB 626 requiring the
Department of Education to administer
the educational Freedom account
yes thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
make a motion for itl
is there a second second
okay we have a motion on the table uh it
was made by represent Belcher itl for
this 626 and second by representative
cordelli uh discussion
uh yes just briefly on this bill we've
uh we've seen it brought that the idea
that this would somehow reduce
administrative costs
um but we we don't have any idea if
that's true we don't know we didn't we
weren't provided with the actual cost
outlook on this we know that the current
the current administration of the
program is running within the mean of
Public School Systems as far as the
administrative costs for this and we
also know that there's going to be
further legislation coming to us shortly
that's going to provide clarification
that more than one organization can be
uh responsible for administering this
program and I believe there's also a bid
coming up on this before too long
represent cordelli
I would uh second those considerations
um I think that we've seen instances in
the past of issues where government
agencies have run similar programs
and uh
I I don't think we want to get into the
situation where a program like this
could be run
um uh efficiently by one Administration
and then a new Administration comes in
and does not look favorably on the
program and
um uh might put the program in Jeopardy
um so I think it's uh
um best left with uh
scholarship organizations or
organizations that are
authorized by uh dra as per current law
further discussion representative miler
oh thank you Mr chair
well there are some known facts that we
have here
nine million dollars which is ten
percent of basically what is given to
other this program
goes to the scholarship organization
and yet there's little oversight to that
nine million dollars
so if you look at some of the uh cost
modules
from the Department which we've seen in
this committee which is about a hundred
and sixty thousand dollars for a staffer
and I I have no idea how many staff the
uh
the scholarship organization has I
believe
that it's about four staff including
executive director and three staff
members
uh We've not had any report from them as
it relates to
how many staff they have Etc but if you
take a hundred sixty thousand dollars
and times it by four or five percent
you're talking about seven hundred
thousand dollars you throw in another
couple hundred thousand dollars for
hardware and software
it's under a million dollars
for the Department to manage the system
by having it in the department you have
greater legislative oversight we have
little legislative oversight right now
the greater legislative oversight these
are taxpayers monies that we're dealing
with here
taxpayers monies that are going to a
private entity that's run out of New
York
to run this program
I would just seem to me that if you want
to have funding for children
in this program
you'd have another what eight nine eight
million dollars that could go out these
children
rather than going to administer a not a
a for-profit Institution
that uh has done this program
it just seen another state other state
entities that have similar programs
they're not as liberal as this one is
but other ones that have similar
programs are run by the Department of
Education
and so it only seemed logical to me that
if we want to have some legislative
oversight
the department is the place it should be
because we have a direct handle on them
we don't have direct handle
on this and I'm disappointed that uh
representatives from the from the
college scholarship organization aren't
here this is the second time we've dealt
with this issue
they haven't been here to basically
provide background to this committee I
don't know why they're not here they've
been here before
uh so
um
I believe that this is the way that we
should do it does not change the program
the funding is still there it's not
repealing the program
it's basically trying to provide
management of millions of taxpayer
dollars
that should be coming out of the
Department of Education
rather than a private entity
so I will definitely be voting against
this IDL and then prepared to put an
ought to pass once this has passed once
this is voted on thank you Mr chair
represent cordial
yes I just wanted to put out there since
I've done some research since the
hearing
um the main office of this organization
that currently runs the program is in
Concord
the organization does have 10 full-time
equivalent employees
there's also
um
it does operate within the parameters
actually less than 10 percent
of administrative costs
and there is oversight
and accountability in that the
um
New Hampshire Department of Revenue must
so another issue this is a question so
those were my just my comments just
sharing some information
that I have uh come across since this is
a very important issue to me and I think
overall with these efas we need to
understand that you know these kids
aren't just dollar signs we need to keep
in mind what is best for the students
um
where is this figure of 90 million
coming from because you you keep
mentioning that and so did
representative luno I actually have in
my notes from the hearing representative
luno referring to
um
nine million dollars the cost of running
it
as he claimed nine million dollars for a
couple of people in an office those are
um
his direct words uh well it's it's more
like 10 people and the nine million
dollars is based on this figure of 90
million dollars where is the figure of
90 million coming from
so that is all for a discussion
further discussion from the committee
represent cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman
um first
um children's scholarship fund is a
non-profit or organization
um secondly
um in statute is the requirement for an
EA EFA oversight committee we met
several times last year
unfortunately the chair a senator
um left and we had no further meetings
that year
appointees have been made by the house
and now by the Senate we got an email
this morning about setting up a meeting
of the EFA oversight committee hopefully
within the next few weeks and it will be
chaired by Senator Ward chair of Senate
education
for further discussion represent
woodcock okay chairman lad um I just
want to uh respond to or follow up on
representative representative
um I'm concerned
confused when we have a special ed
Department that spends millions and
millions of millions of dollars to
ministered by the state of New Hampshire
doe we have a food and nutrition
Department to spends millions and
millions of millions of dollars is
oversight and regulated administrated by
the Department of Education there was
certification and a licensure we have
Adult Ed and the programs go on and on
all these programs spend tax fail money
efficiently uh for the most part and are
organized Enron and administer through
the Department of Education so I
understand why this one particular
facet This One Singular program of all
the programs we do will go to somebody
else
clearly we have a Department of
Education that often is very uh
efficient and successful in mentioning
these types of things
I mean they created it they know what it
is and they have models in every other
state
so I don't understand why we think we
can do this as a Lone Ranger and expend
the nine million or times 90 is actually
times 10 years of the fact that out but
the bottom line is whatever it is we
know it's way over a million bucks a
year well
so it just makes no sense why I wouldn't
trust them to do this as well thank you
Mr chair further discussion
thank you very much Mr chair so
I agree with uh with I think the the
concerns that representative Woodcock
just uh just laid out why is this
program any different you know it's
spending taxpayer and money it's
involving um well in this case
um you know 3 200 students as opposed to
the 165 000 students that that the
department already
um you know works with across the uh the
the state of New Hampshire so why
wouldn't the department be able to
um uh to do this certainly um at a more
reasonable cost than 10 percent of the
program budget
um uh so I I mean what's so what's so
special about this program you know I
thought representative Miler also
brought up um a really good point when
he talked about how liberal this program
is is it it is I mean it's like swiss
cheese and compared to compared to
um other voucher programs that are
seeing uh you know that that that that
are in other states and um and
representative cordelli well actually I
I had a constituent reach out to me when
all this was going down a couple years
ago and said hey you know there's
nothing conservative about this uh EFA
Pro about this program
um so uh so I think representative Miler
characterized it um quite well and then
finally I think to representative
cordelli's uh point is that oh you know
unlike other programs what if a
different Administration comes into the
doe and puts this program in Jeopardy
well it's exactly the lack of
accountability lack of transparency and
lack of oversight of the EFA program
that put this program in Jeopardy and by
having the Department of Education
administer this program at least we'll
see some improvement in these areas
representative cordelli uh thank you
I think this program is a lot more
similar to the tax credit scholarship
program
um than any other program that um uh is
controlled by the Department of
Education and the tax credit scholarship
program is uh something like 11 12 years
old in statute is a 10 percent
administrative cost for that program no
different than this
um uh in terms of the EFA program being
in Jeopardy
um I would
um disagree with that uh vigorously and
that uh I think the EFA program is
extremely successful they're providing
education options
um to over 3 000 children and I would
just say in terms of taxpayer money
those families are getting some of their
tax dollars back actually to educate
their own children
thank you representative Tanner
thank you Mr chair I'd like to point out
that the education tax credit is not
taxpayer money like the education
Freedom accounts are that's number one
number two
um
representative Belcher spoke about
um then in other bills coming that's
going to open up more vendors for this
program which to me means that you need
more oversight because if you look at
this particular bill that outlines what
the scholarship committee organization
does right now it's seven pages of
requirements of setting up surveys of
overseeing monies of setting up
programs it it's very involved what this
scholarship organization already does
so if we have more vendors
doing this
um you know we're going to need more
oversight to make sure that the other
vendors
follow the program that's that's
subscribed in these seven pages that
you'll find in the bill
so
um
I think that's that's a good reason
a couple of good reasons taxpayer money
not not tax credits
and that the fact that if we are going
to open it up to more vendors
we need to have a central place
where there's oversight and central
place where there's
um some guidance on setting up all these
different requirements for this program
thank you thank you very much I do have
a question and and by the way I'm really
pleased to hear that the tax credit
is uh not taxpayer money that's
encouraging that means we're really uh
we're learning right
um so uh going on I'd like to ask the
question and maybe somebody can help me
out uh the scholarship organization is
responsible for administering this
program what kind of dollars have had
they have they had to put into the
program in terms of application
yeah software to manage uh and so if we
take out that cost in the future what
might we see in terms of how much is
needed to manage this program
represent cordelli um thank you we can
look to Arizona the first education
scholarship excuse me education savings
account program in 2011 where they
started out with a manual system and
we've talked in years past about the uh
the audits down there that found
waste and fraud because of the manual
system that could not keep up with the
demand and verifying expenses they are
they moved
to an electronic system
called class wallet
that is the same system that children's
scholarship fund contracted with at the
cost of hundreds of thousands of dollars
but it's a very successful program that
is being used around around the country
and they are actually working with
children's scholarship fund all the time
to develop additional reports detail
reports Etc I talked to the vice
president
um just a couple of months ago about
that
so there are extreme startup costs and
in terms of startup I know for a fact
that other
uh programs that are in the works around
the country
um could not believe that New Hampshire
got the system passed
into law in June and was enrolling
systems in September West Virginia
um took over a year
other states you know aren't even
attempting what we did successfully here
in New Hampshire and I think it's um
thanks to a combined effort of the
Department of Education working with the
children's scholarship fund to make that
happen
and I don't think that
without that
partnership
that could have been accomplished no
other state is even attempting something
thank you so could you do you have any
idea then representative cordelli as far
as the startup costs for class wallet uh
sure I'm sure that to have that program
there's going to be maintenance and
annual costs for the program what will
they be as extensive as they were when
we started up
um I I believe they uh they will not be
and I think the point has been made
previously that
um that will help reduce administrative
costs and every dollar that is reduced
in terms of the administrative costs
will be more money to go to children
and I think that's a significant point
that we should not lose sight of thank
you further further discussion yes
representative Myler uh this is director
that uh representative cordelli since
he's got more inside information than
the most of us do that because of the
startup costs are no longer there do you
anticipate the uh scholarship or the
Children's Fund reducing their 10
request for their management of the
program
uh I would anticipate that
administrative costs are going down
um I think it was actually 9.8 in the
first year from my discussions with them
um I don't have the exact figures to the
cost of class wallet on an ongoing basis
um but we can attempt to get those
and it was it was my understanding that
when we put the RFP initially out there
was one applicant for this job and
that's the scholarship organization
which we have if in fact we go out for
rfps uh which uh you know we most likely
will be occurring
do you expect that the you know being a
market a competitive market that we
might get some responses could do it
cheaper than what we're doing right now
uh that's entirely possible and um if we
can uh do it cheaper and uh um mall for
uh competition competition is uh
wonderful it helps in uh very many
markets including education
Tanner uh that was uh there was no
original RFP for the scholarship
organization when the when the tax
credits were put into place and at that
time there were two organizations the
giving and going Alliance which is a
Christian
um Christian School uh scholarship
organization that that filtered into
that
um so this this organization is based in
New York City it has several other
places that it it provides service so
they get a cut of the money I would
imagine that that is taken for
administration too because they offer
support services and advertising
services to the local scholarship
organization
it's an educational
thing and in other places the Department
of Education hires vendors to do
different things but then oversees those
vendors and the grants
um why not this I mean it's just this is
the same as the other one
um as all the other things that the
department of education does and
um they're the they're the organization
that the taxpayers think
are running things and that that
taxpayers want accountability and fiscal
responsibility for the money that
they're paying to the state
um the money they're paying locally and
and I think the best accountability and
fiscal responsibility comes with the
state organs the State Department of
Education
uh I'm sure this the Department of
Education will be pleased with your
remarks
are there further comments from the
committee representative cordial did you
have your hand up or yeah I I think you
did first though representative
thank you
um I'm not really on this committee so
thank you for letting me speak
um you know that I worked at the
department of Ed and the department of
Ed is um charged with
um the flow of millions and millions of
dollars from the federal government as
well as adequacy
my real concern is the audit
possibilities in terms of how these
funds are being spent and the ability to
audit accurately
um these are taxpayer Monies
following them is a difficult task at
best in the manner in which they're
going out right now
um we our adequacies dollars go out via
the Department of Education
um that's the way it's been going these
dollars are part of those dollars and I
believe that they should belong within
the department of Ed for district for
distribution I think it's just it's
cleaner it's neater I think we're
opening up ourselves for all kinds of
fraud possibilities and problems
um just we want to keep things I think
as legislators it's our responsibility
to do the best job we can to keep things
clean and accurate and audit proof so
I'd like people to consider the
placement of the distribution at the
department of Ed because that's really
where it belongs and I think it would be
served most effectively that way thank
you you're welcome
represent cordial I just want to
re-emphasize I think I mentioned it but
every year the uh
the organization that runs this needs to
reapply to the New Hampshire uh
division of Revenue and registration
that yeah the dra
um and so if they weren't running this
effectively they would not be reapproved
um
just to also point out there was an
independent audit done by Grant Thornton
with all these figures that's one of the
things I found it's posted on the
publicly on their website to um kind of
uh give some transparency to all these
numbers so that's what I kind of based
all my my research on so
thank you further discussion yes
representative cascaden
thank you Mr chair
um I just
is the children's scholarship fund what
that's my first question cordelli yeah
they administer the program yes so
legislature does have oversight yes okay
so my question well not so much a
question is just wondering
the children's scholarship fund
guidelines are posted on the department
of Ed website which includes a record of
educational attainment and then they
recommend it the EFA Law requires all
students renewing a grant must provide a
record of educational attainment does
that mean the New Hampshire law or their
law in general because it doesn't
specify Statewide but it's on our
website and it it gives three options
for a recipient of an EFA to be able to
provide educational attainment
I would think that that
information would be part of the fact
sheet because the primary goal here for
this money is for student growth in
academic skills
class wallet if you go on and take a
look at it is a software system where
families can put in their expense
whether it's at BJ's Costco's Dollar
Tree ballet school and music school
because these are all approved EFA
service providers
and then it comes off the scholarship so
it's like a
you know like a budget item
um but there's no record of student
progress
and our students who are receiving efas
also being screened for dyslexia because
that's still on my my brain but
I just questioned that
they deserve
all the same services for sure
um but yet the same information needs to
be provided for that accountability
piece represent cordelli thank you I
um
well Tom is sole famous author once said
um the basic question is not what is
best but who says what is best
and I think that that is uh firmly
um in the hands of parents
um uh and that's what this program is
geared for unlike other programs
um the parents make decisions on the
educational needs of their child
it's not left to an administrator
in education somewhere it's left to the
parents
administrators staff within teachers
within teachers within schools have sent
their children to Charter Schools Etc or
even homeschool them because they
thought that is what was best for their
child
um and just let me point out one
additional option that is available to
education Freedom account of families
they can actually send their child to a
public school
that's allowed under law they can send
their child to an out of District
public school you know we have we have
districts you know we we rope them in
and if your ZIP code is such and such
this is where you go to school unless
you have the means to send them
elsewhere and we're providing those
families the means to send them
elsewhere and that could be a better
public school
um
um there's a book called redlining
that shows
um Bank redlining in certain
neighborhoods Chicago Los Angeles and
it's very interesting to look at the
overlay of the redlining for banking
institutions with school districts I've
seen it
um in addition
um the story of the author I think it
was his brother in Chicago
um was looking to buy a house and move
his family to Chicago and this road
called North Avenue
they looked they found a beautiful house
they fell in love with south of North
Avenue
but then they discovered they looked at
the proficiency rates of the school and
they were horrified and on the other
side of North Avenue the school was
doing great
so they moved to the other side of the
north North Avenue but as they say in
the book they had to pay an extra 250
000 for a house they didn't like as well
in order to get a better free and
appropriate education for their child it
cost them an extra 250 000 dollars
the discussion represent Balboni
yes my question is involved uh it's kind
of uh basically you mentioned that
there's an oversight committee because
one of the things we're talking about is
accountability but
um the program started two years ago
correct and um how many oversight
meetings have there been and
um what are you looking for when you
have these meetings what kind of
thank you I think that you we also have
to look at just beyond we have oversight
committees too for regular public
education Improvement and assessment
and the oversight committee which is
responsible for overseeing this
particular program has is has that
responsibility to ensure that obviously
that the program has written in statute
is followed and all components of
including the component which you know
where they're we're tracking growth of a
children achievement to students it's
written right in where you can take you
know an assessment test that's Norm
referenced National
test or you can take the Statewide
assessment that data is available and we
do know in the regular High School
situations and and k through eight we
have situations where there are schools
which are not at that proficient Mark we
have a lot of them in certain uh course
areas and we want to see growth and
Improvement there the same thing would
occur in in this program right here uh
but I where I'm really concerned is that
there are a number of programs which are
in place in the EFA program as there are
in charter schools where the the
programs have students coming from the
have real special unique needs and that
we have to measure growth and
achievement of a student many different
ways and and I I've always spoken up and
said I'm not really locked into an
assessment test of some kind Vietnam
reference to what there's so many ways
to
what
will calculate growth and that one of
them is representing Cornelius looked at
is through the parents and through
observing what that child is now able to
do and looking at how that child now
reacts emotionally and socially with
their peers and with others and so I I
think that just as there's a regular
school system
and in the EFA program or the charter
school system there are a number of ways
of doing that and I think the primary
thing that I'm hearing here is that
there's dollars being spent and and
we're taking it away from public
education and that that's that you know
is a very Divergent way of thinking that
I I have on this so that's my two cents
and I got a phone ringing here I owe
everybody lunch or it's not yours
go ahead uh question or if there's
representative Allison uh I just want to
follow up on a comment that
representative cascaden made around
Seth's books uh and
I'm frankly I I don't know but you you
referenced a record three assessment
three possible assessments that were
required under the EFA act yeah one is
portfolio Okay it well then my question
to you when it may be to representative
cordelli as well are those assessed are
those assessments being given
two students and two what are the
results of those assessments on students
right
I'm not aware of what they are so there
are two questions I guess one are the
assessments required with a variety of
possibilities and the second part of the
question is are the results of the
anybody want to respond to that there
are three
forms of assessment that are provided
for in the uh statute the Statewide
assessment and Norm reference assessment
or the portfolio which is the same
language that's in the homeschooling law
um and some of these families
um uh might be homeschooling
um and using an EFA account for uh
online courses
um for curriculum uh for a whole host of
other
um reasons
um so that's entirely appropriate in my
mind as a third alternative for an EFA
family
those Assessments in that process is on
page two of this bill
represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair there's a
lot to unpack in in those those last
comments you know first of all other
than through the voucher program
taxpayers aren't paying for
homeschoolers but um but you know I I
think taxpayers can
taxpayers
have oversight and transparency behind
their Public Schools through through
what are also called school boards in
addition to legislative oversight every
public school district has a school
board and school boards I think by
Statute have to meet at least once every
couple months and I think most me twice
a month at least our school board did
and while I was chair of the school
board
we reviewed
the district manifests so we knew
exactly what uh what money and how much
money how much taxpayer money was spent
on um on wide items and and uh and you
know through that I think
through that level of of oversight both
at the local and the and the state level
taxpayers
have
transparency and can make sure that
their elected officials are accountable
but you know with the information that
that that at least this committee and
whether the oversight committee which I
don't think has met for
probably more than two months unlike
school boards
you you you see
hundreds of thousands of dollars being
spent through vendors like Amazon
Staples Best Buy BJs gun stock Mountain
Dick's Sporting Goods and we don't know
what the mummy's being spent for and
spent on and um and and you know I think
I think the public deserves to know I
think it would make sense for the
Department of Education that already
handles up more than a billion dollars
of public money to be able to taxpayer
money to be able to manage this program
and provide the level of transparency
that uh that I think the the public
taxpayers deserve
go ahead represent Cordell thank you I
just mentioned it in addition to class
wallet
um verifying expenses and expense
categories
every expense submission is reviewed
manually by someone
um I I remember the story I believe we
heard it last year
um of
um request for reimbursement being
denied because they looked up the book
the student with the EFA was in the
fourth grade and this was not a book
appropriate for a fourth grader it was
for a high school kid so they denied the
reimbursement for the book so that kind
of
accountability is being performed by the
children's scholarship fund and that's
part of where the costs come in because
um every item is detailed and verified
that it's appropriate I know that they
have
denied certain certain expenses because
it would be used by other children in
the family as well as the children and
the child with with the EFA so there is
that kind of accountability and I I
think that that's um which maybe drives
some of the expense but also drives the
verification that all these expenses are
truly legitimate expenses for the child
who is the um receiving the EFA
further discussion represent Myler thank
you Mr lead not not to prolong this
conversation because obviously uh those
of us on the respective sides of are
passionate about this this program is in
the state there's no question about that
and I think all this bill is trying to
do is to provide some greater oversight
to the program and greater transparency
represent Balboni asked the question of
how many times has the oversight
committee met and I believe it's met
once uh and I understand the issue of
the change of leadership uh in the
Senate around that but it would seem to
me that if this was a priority of the
leadership and the governor's office
that they would move because of the
controversy of it that they would have
moved to replace that chair and have
more regular meetings on this the other
issue that has not been mentioned yet is
that we've heard before this committee
that um
the management of funds from the depart
from the federal government Etc is
between four and a half and five percent
not ten percent
and so I I just we just believe that 10
is an extraordinary amount of money and
if you want money going to these to the
program that children can benefit from
we would try to we would try to uh
emphasize a fact and then let's make as
much money available as possible rather
than in the management of the system and
I think that our our position is is that
by having it in the department it can be
managed just as as others have said in
an efficient way based upon the billions
of dollars that go out of that
department anyway so the issue of
mismanagement of the of the department
that has not been mentioned it is not
there they can do this system and it
provides a direct contact to this
legislative body
by having it in an independent
organization you don't have that same
same kind of oversight so I would
encourage people to recount of rethink
their position I know this is an
important issue for all of us regardless
of what our position is and I I would
recommend Mr chair that we move to vote
on this
I would also support that recommendation
so we have a motion on the table right
now to uh itl the bill and we're on 6
26th the recommendation was made by uh
representative Belcher in second by
representative cordelli in that motion
as itl on 626 requiring the Department
of Education to administer the education
Freedom account uh
Madam clerk are you ready to call the
roll
uh yes the chairman uh Vice chairman
cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no representative
Lane no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock no
representative Heath no representative
Albany no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days 10 10 represent the
lunar um make a recommendation I'll move
OTP
and second by whom okay so we have a
recommendation of a motion for uh OTP by
representative luno and a a second from
represent miles representative would you
like to speak the emotion you're right
to vote
is that okay with you two representative
absolutely thank you so Madam clerk when
you're ready we will call the
Representative blackis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortielo no
representative Miler yes representative
Lane yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
balbooni yes representative cascadden
yes representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd no 10 years 10 days
so obviously folks we've got no
recommendation coming out of the
committee there will be a report from
the minority and the majority on that
and we'll go from there
yes sir
yeah and uh
okay so
um we're closing on lunch but I noticed
that we have safety here and I don't
want to keep our law enforcement sitting
in our room all day
so we're going to forego our lunch right
now at this particular point in time and
we're going to go on to uh HB 267
uh this is a bill that's relative to
criminal records checks and school
employment
um I'm going to open it up a little bit
of a discussion here first
um
so that we can and I won't take any
motions during this discussion but it's
opened up to discussion
um
reps and Milo are a little you came to
me earlier just before and saying we'd
like to go this route
um do you would you like to lead off
with some
um questions or well I think uh take
some more information all right thank
you Mr chair I think our concern is and
this this bill
uh provides an opportunity for school
districts to do multiple uh background
checks and I think we had some concern
about why that needs to be done it also
it also designates groups
that could be done and we had some
concerns about the cult the quote groups
and whether or not that might be
somewhat discriminatory from a
standpoint of how this might be
implemented now we recognize that
that this is subject to a collective
bargain agreement and would have to be
negotiated but we just we just don't
understand there was testimony before
the committee that talked about
some of the staff that never received
one because of the timeline of when this
was implemented these were would be some
of the senior staff on in a school
district and
um so we were wondering whether or not
that they might be an exception that
they could go back and do a background
check they were just several questions
that we really had about
the need and whether or not this is a
bill in search of a problem so that I
think Mr chair that was that was some of
the concerns that we have thank you
representative cordelli thank you uh I
think as I recall from the testimony
um the groups a language any group of
employees who was meant to
um uh eliminate the possibility of
background checks being conducted on
certain individual employees which I
think would create many many more
problems
um and uh I think that
if a background check is done
um January 1st
and never repeated on that employee that
is a large problem
um they could get arrested and convicted
of any crime uh you know a few months
later
um
I think that we need to provide the
flexibility for school districts to do
background checks
on a recurring basis as they see fit
furthest representative Damon
I don't think children's safety should
be a function of zip code if we need to
improve the frequency of criminal record
checks I think it should be attached to
re-licensing and be a consistent
Statewide system
that I just don't understand why it
representative Luna
thank you Mr chair and and I don't say
this very often but I agree with what
representative cordelli
um was just saying about about about
student safety and I agree with what and
I'm going to put these together and
agree with what represent Damon
um you know said uh said about this and
and making sure that that some districts
do it some way some districts don't do
it don't do it at all and I think that's
largely the reason why we'd like to we'd
suggest to work on this bill
um for uh for this year and uh and bring
it bring it forward with an amendment
during the second year of this uh
biennium so that so that it actually
solves a problem and and doesn't you
know doesn't create either other
problems or or you know or Worse
um well creating other problems is
pretty bad but or actually not solve uh
the problem that it's um that it's doing
and and um
and so so I I would hope we'd hold on to
it and work on it okay I I do have a
question here and maybe our
our individual here has been a
commissioner or a Deputy Commissioner of
doe or maybe represent cascadden who's
been an administrator is a teacher's
ticket now renewed in this state mine
was renewed every five years I had to go
back and take so many courses to get my
certification renewed is it three or
five years or what is the time frame now
does anybody know that of the two that I
asked
I believe it's every three years for
certification The Five-Year Mark is
tenure
well okay that which is another issue
that's another issue yeah certifications
every three years every three years okay
I think that's where where I was yes
a few years ago when I left it was every
three years every three
okay good
yes representative Miler one of the
things that we are that we've been
talking about even this morning was the
issue of of student safety and
child safety and I think one of the
questions is I in my notes reflect here
there was a question about
uh service providers under the EFA
program and how do we ensure that those
service providers are in fact would
follow would they fall under the same
kind of Aegis from a standpoint of
ensuring that uh that their background
checks are similar to if we if we want
to move in this direction uh then how do
we deal with all those uh individuals
who are basically going to have a chance
to to uh educate uh students so that was
but that was a question that that line
of thinking is going to be very
Divergent from the chapter of law we're
in here this section which is dealing
with employees of schools Charter
Schools Etc you look at right at the top
of the bill what's to say the employee
school administrative Unit School
District Public School
um it was just a question yeah but so I
I think if we can keep it to this that
scope
um
I think we'll get probably to some kind
of conclusion here representative cascad
thank you Mr chair
um
just want to point out that record chips
record checks for substitute teachers
within the same SAU are required every
three years by Statute
and I know this is asking for School
Employees and volunteers
and I wonder I mean I have to go back
and check this but
the pool of people who have never had a
criminal record check pre the law
probably should have one
but then moving forward once an employee
has had one does a code of ethics or the
in the code of conduct
sort of screen anything that an employee
might do out on the street or out in the
community that's a violation
isn't there something in those two
booklets that would trigger
um some disciplinary action possibly yes
that it wouldn't need a follow-up
criminal I don't know three layers of
occurrence that can uh be applied to an
individual who is in contrary to that
code of professional conduct and and uh
we had a long discussion with that Brian
you are part of that discussion several
years ago or a year ago and we wrote a
letter an administrative letter from
this committee here to doe suggesting
that maybe there'd be a fourth which was
a lesser of the other three steps are
presently there
um but I'm I'm interested in knowing
if in fact in your administrator you
know uh you have a individual that is
um and let's stop it a notch
um with a youngster in a car so then
comes aggravated or yeah aggravated so
if that occurs does that put you into
position where you have to make the
decision or is the decision made for you
that they're they're you know no longer
being to be a teacher
I would make that decision that um
first is a leave
until an internal investigation is done
um usually a police department would do
an investigation as well separate
um might warrant disciplinary action but
I think the teachers union would guard
against full dismissal
so it's it's a process that's where I'm
aiming I think that there's a lot of
variables in making that decision yeah a
lot of variables and so with that
there's got to be some discretion so I'm
looking at these the these checks and
I'm just want to make sure that we're
not going to take that that ability of
the administration right to look at this
totally and would support people that
you have and come up with the right
decision rather than saying you're out
the door and you've lost your ticket
right a lot goes into it before it gets
to that point Thank You representative
thank you Mr chair just a quick question
because I know it's it's come up before
in in during hearings during discussion
but um it does does the um does FBI have
to approve or weigh in on on any
language let's have safety okay that
good afternoon members of the committee
and thank you for the opportunity I'm
captain Vic Muzzy I'm in charge of the
Justice information Bureau for the State
Police and uh yes representative to
answer your question any language
changes would have to be submitted to
the FBI
um we just attended a conference last
week in Seattle
discussing the difficulties with that
office at the moment at the FBI they're
very short staffed the turnaround time
can be quite extensive I think
two years ago we maybe had to wait eight
or ten months for a review and approval
for 189.13 a through C
so that is a problem at the moment but
yes
um given that the language change we
would have to have
that review by the FBI and follow up Mr
chair so so
um you know thank you Captain Muzzy for
uh for joining us this morning thank you
for the question and and helping us
through this
um would would it be possible that that
we could work with you to um you know if
if we retain the bill and and and are
looking at developing some language to
maybe have the best shot at getting
approval of what you know language that
would would you know maybe be acceptable
yes and this in fact came up in the
discussion last week where
the conference we were at was uh
involved in multiple States I can't say
every state but and we've tried to do
just that is share language between
states that we know has been approved
prior by the FBI and that seems to be
not an exact science so in other words
other states have adopted similar
language that they know has passed that
process when that's been submitted by
that state for some reason it's been
rejected or returned and what have you
so I think yes we can do that the other
thing I'll say and I'm not really sure
on the answer of this but the earlier we
can submit this for approval or not the
better in other words I don't know if
it's appropriate to submit a bill that
hasn't passed just to see if in its
current form it would I don't know if
that's I'd have to do some research
myself and you folks probably know more
than I do so far as that goes but that
comes to mind so that we don't have the
delay that we suffered with 189 13 and
having to wait 10 months before we can
act on it because we're at the hands of
the FBI to decide for us whether or not
it's acceptable so certainly I think
those conversations in that process we
would be open to that to make sure that
we're not unnecessarily delayed and
whatever the determination may be thank
you
thank you are there further
representative thank you chairman Kevin
thank you and thank you for waiting
around and taking these yeah no problem
uh glad to be here to follow uh in your
conference or in your dialogue with the
other fellow uh people in your capacity
in the other states is that do you know
or have a record of any states that have
annual or research with licenses as part
of the statute
not specifically no okay so you know
that that's happening out there no with
this you mean for this process in other
states if it's happening I mean yeah for
and for other states uh they do
recertification do you know of any
states that require or it's like tag
it's attached to part of their process
recertification I'm not okay
thank you further further questions
represent Cass cabin
um just looking at the Statue there is a
section of the 189 13c the criminal
history records check on a candidate is
valid for a period of three years which
if the committee was going towards every
certification period it would match this
are there any yes represent Milo thank
you Mr chair uh captain could you
outline for us what goes into a criminal
records check I mean how does it how
does it work
certainly I don't know if
my partner here would join me
um I mean since we're both here so I I
can explain it from I think probably
somewhat of the same level but
um
well I'll let you explain
the resident expert good afternoon my
name is Christine Shea and I'm the
criminal records unit supervisor
and as far as the criminal records
background checks
with that you get two portions to that
we have the state only check which for
Education you get everything
um and then we submit the fingerprints
to the FBI and the FBI sends us
everything that they have from the other
states
in which you receive all the records as
well on that
well yes what kind of records are you
looking at
any criminal records that they have
that are fingerprint based so any charge
if they were arrested for
drugs if they were arrested
for I mean the list is extensive yeah so
maybe I can help explain a little bit
um
a criminal record consists of things
like complaints as accepted for filing
arrests and dispositions so each
incident we'll call it has a cycle and
typically you'll see on the on the
criminal record things are are
delineated by cycle and so there's
usually three entries for every incident
those being the complaints that were
filed at the court or the arrest the
complaints that were filed at the court
and then the disposition that comes from
the court
um
and so we have that a state record now
our state record may or may not be
fingerprint supported which means
offenses that you're convicted of in in
criminal offenses that you're convicted
of in New Hampshire will appear on your
New Hampshire only record reason being
is the FBI doesn't care what your name
is the FBI cares what your fingerprints
look like and that's the only data that
they will put on their record is is
those instances that are fingerprint
supported so the state record may
actually have more information on it
than the federal record because of the
way information gets on the federal
record which has to be by fingerprints
and the best example I can think of is
if you're in a DW if you if if an
individual were to be involved in a car
crash let's say and they were accused
and found guilty of of drunk driving
they may be in the hospital and so that
investigation that goes on that person
may be hospitalized we may not get
fingerprints for that arrest and thereby
that offense would not appear on the
federal record but would appear on their
state record and so that's why that the
records can can be and sometimes are
different now every state
a record if you will that has
fingerprints you're going to see those
on both records so you'll see it on the
state record and on the FBI record so
um in the FBI record often you know
contains the same Cycles if you will
that the state record does so it's
um
from what we've heard from the industry
it's a lot of information typically
um and and we've done some trainings
with attorney Fenton to help the saus
and and administrators understand what
that information means how to get how to
look at it how to interpret you know
what might be there and things so
um
for us we don't have you know a state
fingerprint we rely on the FBI so I you
know all of our fingerprints um get
submitted to the FBI and there's there's
been some discussion on uh State checks
with fingerprints that's not the way
that we we operate at the moment so we
have to rely on the FBI for those things
so
I guess that hopefully answers the
question yeah yeah I I
two two questions one are there any
charges that can be exonerated
from the record one and two what is the
fee for the criminal record check
yes to answer your first question
through the process of an annulment
um so we basically you know the person
would go to court and they would file
for an annulment that would be reviewed
and if the court decided yes this charge
can be annulled we get notice of that
that's a manual process for us now when
we go in and literally delete that from
the record
um and the charge for a state
um conviction check is twenty five
dollars okay
and the charge for an annulment is a
hundred if you're if you're asking as
far as the FBI check just so there's two
different fees there for the FBI check
which would include this state check is
40.25 for an employee
um and 21.25 for a volunteer
which includes the FBI and state check
I have a question regarding your FBI the
what you get from the FBI we have a
number of
well not a number out but we do have
teachers or administrators or folks
working in schools that are coming in
that may be Canadian or does the FBI
check go further and that I'm not
picking on Canada you know but I was
brought up there so
um so what my my question would and I'm
not checking for myself either but uh
but I I'm curious to know whether when
you do your FBI check that there's any
linkage with the where this individual
may have come from
internationally
internationally I would need to get
clarification on that for you
um they will tell us as far as the state
they were born in in that kind of
information but as far as if it's
International I have to research that a
little further thank you for what it's
worth we do see military charges you
know on a record at times I can't say as
I've ever seen a foreign charge or a
charge from another another place but
certainly military you know charges are
on there and which can be sometimes
difficult to discern what the outcome of
those may have been and
yeah I've I've been there and done that
article of what five or so started out
as a young officer and
you're acting like judge jury and
everything in one time right
um
so are there further questions
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair and I apologize if I
missed this So currently yeah school
system employees are going through the
so that would Encompass if they had a
situation in another state prior to
being here
once they get the federal check that's
based off their fingerprints so that's
gonna link any other charges from
another state thank you for clarifying
so
if you sit there just a second based
what I'm hearing here there seems to be
some very good questions which have been
asked from the committee and good
information we've heard from the the
department
I I'm getting close to the point where
we may don't want to take any action
it's not an early bill
and we may want to really sort through
this a little bit more
and
um and work with you and maybe I can
talk with Eddie Edwards when he comes
over for the public school
infrastructure commission and and work
with him too but I I think there's much
more we have to learn here so we don't
step somewhere where we're you know
going to end up next year trying to undo
what we did this year
um
so and I just think from our standpoint
based upon what we've heard of it's
called siegelu and that's an acronym
that I suppose stands for something it's
just fun to say so far is the opposite
the FBI that reviews these things and
um we literally spoke last week about
trying to get a training from them to
help educate us on what the standard
should be uh so that we're not
unnecessarily wasting time and there was
quite healthy discussion on some
struggles that other states had had
adopting similar language from a
neighboring state that had been passed
and things like that and then all of a
sudden they're up against this wall so
the industry from our perspective is
trying to find a way to help smooth this
process out understanding that all the
other states are suffering from the 10 8
or 10 month delay and again I think
thinking proactively is where I'm coming
from when I say I don't know what point
it would be appropriate to send them
proposed language and I you know I'm not
familiar with whether that would be a
good practice or not or whether that's
possible but as I see it I just don't
want to run into a delay like we had
before in that in that instance
um I think that's certainly advisable
that we consider doing that so we don't
run down the path
you know go farther down the rabbit hole
and have to figure out how to get out of
yeah yeah
we should be always clearing stuff
through you know people like Diana
Fenton and yeah and and you guys and
maybe even across the street yeah you
know and I would say in this case
in my personal opinion you know what
you're not asking the FBI to release
their record
to another body or another group you're
really saying we just want to release it
more often so in theory I think the the
intent of the bill should be fine I'm
not the FBI and I don't know how they
think on a daily basis but it I would
see a bigger hang up if we were trying
to disseminate their record to a new
group of people that would be probably
cause more concern versus what we're
really saying is here we just want to do
this on a more frequent basis which I
can't imagine would be a problem but
again I don't I don't want to speak out
of turn on that either thank you Captain
it's been good Vice
so uh yeah I just like to not take any
action right now so if we have to do
something we have to March 16th where we
have to make a decision on this so we
got some time here and we'd very much
like to work with you further on this
certainly and we'll get Diane involved
with it as well
we'll put a subcommittee together and
and yeah I know committees are
committees but this one right here is
it's important and we in support we do
it right
so so thank you once again I want to
thank you for waiting for your lunch
break and we did have a little bit in
the back of the room that you were going
to break for lunch ahead of time so I'm
disappointed that I didn't bet I would
have I would have had a free lunch well
thank you for waiting you're welcome to
join me I got peanut butter and jelly
sandwich here a little lunchtime humor I
wanted to say thank you for her thank
you very much thank you thank you
so with that we're not going to take any
action on this bill right now and we're
going to break for our lunch
yeah and we have
about five or so bills left to do today
so we should be able to clean up fairly
quickly so let's come back around one
o'clock
if you need a little bit more time if
you're going to the cafeteria lines yes
yeah and and during that lunch the
Republicans will caucus
pardon me oh okay
Linda work I'm not going to start to 1
15. it's a 12 15 we'll start at 1 15 if
okay
foreign
will have a subcommittee work on that
bill and we also are going to have a
subcommittee work done on the
indemnification stuff
but um now we're down to the next one
here which is dealing with HB 380
uh FN relative non-academic surveys
administered by a public school or a
Charter Public School to its students
representative McDonald you recognized
is there a second
second
okay represent cordial he beats
representative Ford
so the motion's been made by represent
McDonald's second by representative
cordelli referencing 380. it's open to
discussion from the maker of the motion
thank you Mr chair I have some serious
concerns with this bill which is why I
made the motion of itl but the biggest
being that non-academic surveys since
they are not related to academics we
need to give parents and students
increased awareness of what they are
agreeing to so changing this to an
opt-out policy might make some students
and parents unaware of what they're
agreeing to and that's just my primary
concern among a few other reasons so
thank you you're welcome representative
cordelli
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to add
to the record on this one that despite
some of the testimony we heard I have
done a bit of research and
um this bill does specifically exempt
from the ability to opt out
um CDC developed surveys beyond the
youth risk assessment survey my research
shows that there are other CDC surveys
that have been developed including some
very concerning looking ones coming down
from the World Health Organization and
the United Nations so there would be
theoretically a whole lot of surveys
Exempted by this bill so represent
Belcher can you please explain a little
bit more for me on this one we have the
CDC survey that we're talking about with
the exception in law the youth risk
behavior survey
correct now is this bill opening it up
to other uh CDC surveys correct if you
look at the language of this bill it
opens it up to any CDC develop survey
can you show me where that is in 3A
um I think it's lines 12 and 13. there
yeah
working
56 funded by the CDC right
okay
further discussion representative Tanner
these are prevention programs as listed
in here
um and you said that the these surveys
that open it up to the world have uh U.N
or World Health Organization type
surveys they they wouldn't be
appropriate for this
as a prevention survey would they
if I may answer that because this
language in the bill opens it up to CDC
surveys the specific surveys I'm
speaking to in my research are CDC
surveys that have been developed in
conjunction with the World Health
Organization and the United Nations and
UNESCO
so yes those organizations are directly
involved for prevention
I I don't have the name of them right in
front of me at the moment
represent Damon
I'd like to add thank you I'd like to
ask representative Belcher for further
clarification because that line
uh 12 into 13. clearly says surveys
related to other I'm emphasizing
prevention as representative Tanner did
and also funded by the Centers for
Disease Control and prevention CDC is
not funding UNESCO or the World Health
Organization
uh yeah I don't believe I've ever made
any claim that would contradict that
these are CDC surveys they are available
on the the at least the descriptions on
the CDC website and they are partnered
with UNESCO the UN and the World Health
Organization in developing and
administering these surveys specifically
designed to be administered to school
represent miler
thank you Mr chair I think the important
part of this as I see is that it
provides notice prior to any of these
surveys being given and I think the
Dilemma that we've had before
is that uh the opt-in uh I think uh
these first of all these surveys are
done to help
schools and other agencies to identify
issues that need to be addressed in
schools or in communities
and by having the current opt-in program
the issue of the reliability of the
numbers that need to be taken to to make
these reliables the results reliable uh
is is difficult by opting out
parents can do that as it says here that
the written notice is given to students
are listed on electronically on websites
Etc so
it would seem to me that we'd want to
get some of this data
so that the various service agencies
assisting
student Behavior Etc and other needs
that need to be addressed in school in
schools and communities needs to be done
so I I don't understand why there's a
problem there
okay we're going to just take a break
for a second I had uh the
um Deputy Chief of Staff just inform me
due to the severe weather we are
currently experiencing the temperatures
plummeting right now speaker Packard is
recommending legislators who are parked
at the store Street Garage park closer
to the state house and lob before
temperature drops further and the wind
picks up if you're parked at stores a
street garage today please feel free to
take a break at your convenience to go
move your car closer we currently have
space available in the upper lob garage
which is accessible via Capital uh
Street that's right over here in the
side in various Street spaces and
various speeds Street spaces around the
complex which are identified by the
yellow legislative bags Protective
Services can assist you in finding a
space if you have any trouble
do we have any people here that would
like to take advantage of that right now
because we're going to be here for I
would say at least to 3 30.
um
and and um it's going to be a little
if you want to if you want to move right
now
you can probably get a ride down there
too instead of having a walk down there
I have something to do with the danger
in the garage it's just that extreme
temperature
okay uh so it's not you don't have to do
anything if you don't want to do it but
if somebody wants to you know we can we
can you know take a short short break
and you can hit hit you know the garage
and get your car up here and park it
right in back of the building here where
there's lots of spaces available
foreign
they'll do that for you
you can buzz it and they'll just open
you up
we will we will discuss but because of
this we will not take any action on
well what I would suggest you know
um
when you go down go to the desk where
you see Bob down there and ask him we'd
like to go to the garage but we'd like
unless you feel you can do it quickly
and ask them how long it takes the fan
thank you when it comes to four degrees
I don't know how you can tolerate
380.
off topic I just checked whether on top
of Mount Washington and are down
approaching minus 30.
tonight
minus 30 degrees
no that's real temperature that's the
real temperature that we're not quite
there yet but by late afternoon they
expect to be down about minus 30.
okay
HB 380 we're discussing this relative
non-academic surveys administered by a
public school or a Charter Public School
trying to recoup where we were
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to add some
further contacts and perhaps correct a
little bit of testimony we heard before
a Break
um it was stated that their
um is opt-in opt-out procedures and such
uh for CDC related surveys but I would
note that the language in the bill
actually says the policy shall include
an exception from the consent
requirement for the Youth risk behavior
survey developed by the CDC goes on to
add to continue that exemption to this
new language that expands it beyond the
that survey to all CDC uh potential
surveys and then it strikes the part of
the policy that would allow for an
opt-out so there would under this be no
I just wanted to
I guess give an anecdote
um people say well it's it's on notices
given and that notices I don't think has
struck out
um notices given so the parents would
know
but the problem is
notices given by putting it someplace on
the school district website and when my
granddaughter was living with me during
High School I was on that website every
day I was in communication with her
teachers every day right
that website is huge I didn't read the
whole website every day I was on I was
in communication with her teachers I was
looking at how she was doing every day I
never saw a notice and then my
granddaughter came home absolutely upset
with me mad at me grandma why didn't you
walk me out do you know what that stuff
asked it was so embarrassing I mean she
was just she was a very private person
and the idea that even people were
asking her these questions was extremely
upsetting to her she didn't talk to me
for two hours
she was so mad at me and that was not
normal for her but she was so mad at me
because she had to and they told her she
had they didn't say oh as a student you
can decide not to do this they didn't
tell her that
and and that she had to answer these
private personal questions that she
didn't you know she was very private
still is very private
and I I still remember that that was so
upsetting to her that she had to answer
yes representative Woodcock just a
clarification that representative's
comment
um like under the 1819 when they have
the new Doc policy and then talk to
another bill it says that they're right
there that the the parents have gotten
can opt out of their neck of a survey
and I understand what you're looking at
that was or where it's lined out but
that puts it back in down there and see
they can either do electronically you
need to write another more so that
that's in there it has this has
safeguards it's on the website it's 10
days in advance the schools have it in
their hand the kids know what's coming
they advertise it and and then parents
can opt out Simply electronically just
quick by doing else and I think it's
well I think we're making it more than
it really is represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair I'd just like to add
that the what representative Blake has
just said about her granddaughter we
should really stop and take a minute to
think if students feel that way they
feel embarrassed at school no student
should be made to feel that way because
of a survey that as it is written in the
context of the bill has no academic
value and the survey mentioned the
youthless behavior survey well I took
that survey twice in 2020 and 2022 was I
told that this was something I could opt
out of no I was not students are not
made aware that they have that ability
and parents are not made aware and there
also is no follow-up procedure in place
and well we did have testimony from DHHS
who is also present today
and I believe they have the best of
intentions and I'd like to think that
but the survey itself has no direct
benefit to students or teachers because
they don't have access to the survey
results that are Anonymous anyway and
there is concern about the accuracy of
results when students make a joke of
such a survey anyway so it really has no
value and it's even noted no academic
value so it really shouldn't be in opt
out types that it should be opt-in and
that's
just seems fundamental to me
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair a couple of things
one it's not only electronic notice in
fact what it actually says is written
notice sent home with a student and then
in addition to the written notice may be
provided electronically so the situation
that happened with representative
Lucas's granddaughter is not what this
bill says it's not only electronic you
don't have to search a website there is
notice set
I would just like to speak as a public
health person to the incredible value of
data to drive decision making about
how we educate what we need to know what
the problems are
and saying that this doesn't have
academic benefit does not resonate for
me because the situations that the
surveys obtain information on relate to
an individual's ability to benefit from
education you can't learn if your mental
health status is not addressed you can't
learn
if a variety of other situations are
happening that the data from these
surveys help us to be able to address I
think it's
it's good public policy to get the best
survey data we can which would mean the
most subjects available thank you yeah
okay we got we got a lot of bills in
front of us here and of course we got
the youth risk behavior survey it's
already in statute and how we do things
uh this is changing that around how much
more time we want to spend on commenting
amongst ourselves here on it is
something we ought to consider we got
these other bills coming
if we
want to support this let's just go ahead
and show that if we want to be you know
just remain with what we got in statute
let's go the other way
um but let's skip the comment stuff done
so we can get you know on with the other
so we do have a motion on the table
to itl this bill
but that would mean is we just stay with
the Statue we have in the books right
now
and and so
um I guess I would you know unless
there's somebody that really has I don't
want to cut it off totally but if
somebody has something please let me
know right now because I'm ready to call
the roll here
okay ma'am Clark we we have a motion on
the table it's itl uh 380. this is
relative to non-academic surveys
administered by a public school or
Charter Public School to its students
representative leckis
yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative yes oh hold on a second
sorry
six seven okay
representative cortiella yes
representative miler no
representative Elaine no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no
representative Ellison oh representative
representative Heath no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes
10 years 10 Nays
motion Mr chair yes not the best
person makes motions the second by
represent Damon
Myler no I'm fine thank you rep stamen
Vice chairman cordelli
no
representative Lucas
representative Ford no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
Representative no no Representative
cortielo no representative Miler yes
representative Lane yes representative
Tanner yes representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman LED no
you said you're going to write the
report for uh itl the bill oh it doesn't
representative said I'm sure it's
okay
thank you
next bill which we have on the docket is
638 this is relative to extraordinary
need grants to schools
.
foreign
okay this is relative to the
thank you Mr chairman I uh call on you
for a motion I'd like to recommend OTP
on 638
is there a second
from Mr representative Miler uh
discussion representative land thank you
very much uh we've had some discussion
on on this extraordinary needs Grant
even yesterday I believe we were
discussing it
um
I think you all know why the the Bill's
been put in where for those that
received less than fifty thousand
dollars there's we're spending more
money oftentimes in terms of
those that are creating the report then
they're receiving from the grant itself
and so uh therefore the the putting
forward of this particular bill
um it's it's just another part of this
whole funding formula which we have to
address this and the relief Grant and
fiscal capacity disparity so I won't say
for the comments representative Tanner
um yeah I just would like a little
Clarity on this
um under section two
um a it says the accountability plan
will not be a conditional requirement
and then down in B it says a school
district that shares a town with another
school district will result in both
districts being required to complete the
accountability plan under two
um
so I just it sounds contradictory
contradictory to me
um could you explain an individual
District
in a that receives this grant
um
that's applicable too but if they're in
a district that shares a town with
another
with another school district so you're
talking about two districts or more
there
I think that's how I'm reading that uh I
thought it was like cooperatives
statistics it could be that too and one
is required and one isn't to complete
the accountability
you know it says both are both districts
and it says it's
the accountability plan will not be a
conditional requirement and then in part
two it said it's being required to
complete the plan
so
I
uh if both districts individually are
exempt
but you take the disc Co-op that has
them both within that Cooperative
District then they wouldn't be exempt
right it would total up more than 50
Grand
I I that's how I'm seeing that oh okay
this is the cleanup bill from doe it's
nothing that we have created it's we've
received these type of things and bang
we put them Forge this is basically a
Caitlyn Bill does this does this grant
go to the town or does it go to the
district
maybe that's the difference
[Music]
do you think it goes to the town and the
money's from the town then are
transferred over to the district it goes
to the municipal first
and that's why we had these these
I I just still see it as uh one
contradict contradicting the other
but
represent like us
I just have a question
um on what these reports
how detailed
they have to be
I mean we know that a district is 50
000 it's because but it could still be a
small amount per School approved based
on the number of students but do they
have to just give a general report
overall for the district or does it have
to be what they provided for the student
that student and that student
has to be in accordance with the
language which we put in the
extraordinary needs Grant Bill
that Aaron Hennessey put forward last
year it stipulates exactly what's the
accountability Grant's supposed to I
think it's much of the similar language
that you would find out of the uh 2018
report
that task force
I don't have the extraordinary
experience it's um it's
19840f Roman 2 on page 758 in your
textbook yeah I can get it right here
too
it says in order to receive an
extraordinary need Grant the eligible
School District shall provide a plan to
the Department of Education outlining
how the district intends to use the
grant award funds to improve the
educational achievement and growth of
students
the extraordinary need Grant plan shall
include an accountability component
designed to generate data that measures
student academic achievement and growth
of Knowledge and Skills in reading and
language arts inter-mathematics at what
Etc yes and that was in SB 420 it was
submitted on May 17 2020 and it was 2038
was the amendment number I got it in
front of me right here from our our
record last year and it is that it is
that language that we have for
the these exceptions to filing if it's
50 000 or whatever it might be
um
but it's still it is it still the non
it's not a condition of requirement for
this grant uh to or for the
accountability plan to be received to
receive the extraordinary needs Grant
that's correct that's what he says yeah
yes
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis
no
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative core tiello
yes
representative Myler yes
representative Lane yes
representative Tanner
yes
representative Lou now yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years one day
and the objections to a consent
okay
yeah
yeah that was one of the early bills we
Army
people this but but see this was
not changing any money at all this was
simply changing policy associated with
it
it does
um let me look at that and see if what
it was specifically saying FM due to
time constraints the office of
legislative budgets is unable to provide
a fiscal note for this bill
as introduced at this time
I don't know how this was going to
create more money all stipulating as far
as whether you have to comply with a
report
basically
we have a lot of bills that are coming
down without fiscal notes representing
Heath and we have a hard time
understanding which ones are early
versus the other ones which probably
should be early and maybe this one
we'll we'll put it on our consent and if
okay she's got the depart then that's
not it's all for consent
okay going on to the next one HP 424 100
members
thank you
this is relative to school lunch payment
policies
we want to you know I'll make a motion
so we can just move on yeah uh thank you
Mr chairman I uh call on the chairman
for a motion uh yes I'd like to make the
motion oh uh itl on this bill 424.
is there a second okay
there's your second is representative
Ford
um chairman Ladd for a comment
um yes uh first thing I'd like to say I
don't know how we get a a fiscal cost to
this thing other than they're saying
that in this bill if a student's unable
to pay for a meal or what was a meal
debt no the the school is prohibited
um
and not providing that are requiring
something like I guess chores or other
work or uh or some way that compensates
for the meal
um
and it says require school to direct
communication about child's meal debt to
a parent or guardian and not the student
nothing in this section shall prohibit a
school from sending a student what I'm
trying to say is I don't see any
Financial costs do this thing
and yet here we are another bill which
is an early Bill and with an FN on it
um I I for one you know
would never do something as a school
principal where it's demeaning to any
youngster
we expect we used to have kids fighting
over helping put the folding tables back
back up against the wall or to take a
sponge and wash off the surface
um
we never did any cleaning well you know
anything like that it was just
associated with it it was sometimes it
was kids that didn't want to go for
recess on that minus 10 day
um
so um Rick it's not an early build okay
FN that the FN yeah that's
Duo 316. yeah okay so so
that that's my thoughts on this thing I
think that this is trying to write a
policy for our school district when it's
a local Affair and a local can do it the
local can
knows that the students and can make
these decisions without us having to say
now we need you know to do it this way I
know for a lot of the lunch serving
people it's difficult times when you're
trying to collect debt at the end of the
school year that can be a real hard hard
issue and there's some that owe a lot of
money
and uh that that's that's a burden on
school districts I'd rather see
something where the school district
who's tried to make those efforts they
get compensated for that in some way uh
if they're not going to get it out of
the apparent and perhaps uh somebody
that's been here you know in the field
recently might be do you ever get
reimbursed for something like that I
don't think you do this you absorb that
debt so uh that's I I introduced it so
that was my little Spiel
um representative foreign
that's what I'm trying to get to thank
you
um it's it's the Local District that
bears the cost if you look at this bill
because they're responsible
at the end of the year to tap their
general fund to pay off the debt
um I can remember as an early or a young
principal
if somebody didn't pay for their lunch
they got a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich no that's not discriminating
and then the law came out some law came
out and said no they get a hot meal like
everybody else and nobody knows so thank
goodness that did change because
obviously that would stigmatize
I don't know what this law would do as
you were saying
um because the cost no matter what the
debt is and there's a process through
the business offices that if there's a
high debt then a letter is mailed home
from the business office to offer
payments plan or and we always threaten
small claims court but it's after
multiple letters so you've got your data
and I think in my 10 years who took one
to court we got the money but it was
after multiple annual you know going
after and it wasn't that the parent
couldn't
um it was just you know ignoring the
whole situation so I don't know what
this bill would do today
that isn't already happening
which is similar to what you are saying
that's not what I thought initially that
did was exactly what I'm currently
seeing up in Sao 23 yeah I see them
having to go through and when they do go
it's in the real expense in the part of
the district so basically they're
absorbing this debt and
um I think that's the big issue it is
that's the big issue it's it's the kids
are being fed the big issue is the debt
right that's right we need more money
I I think I beg to differ with you Mr
chair
I think this bill is focused on not
stigma stigma having a hard time with
words here stigmatizing students as a
result
of not paying it I mean we we've we've
we've heard this problem before
and to me it goes Way Beyond who's
getting the letter Etc it's it's to
making sure that a child
does not go through a lunch line and and
somehow is stigmatized because it's not
being paid I mean I think I think that's
the intent of this bill unless unless
I'm misreading it
the the the fact is in the districts
I've had the kids are fed and they're
fed the same food the the that's that's
not the issue I don't think we're
stigmatizing the kids I think the issue
is we're not reimbursing the schools for
the debt that they're incurring and
they're putting the schools in a
situation where they have to chase this
money if they want a receipt and that
and sometimes it's significant dollars I
I was looking at one account which was
over a thousand dollars
that's huge
representative Tanner I just worry that
um I know schools have been pressured to
to get outside vendors because the you
know it's supposed to balance out the
the
income and out uh the expenses uh it's
supposed to be independent
um that maybe some of these vendors have
kind of
gone uh to collection agencies or
um pressure tactics that the school
wouldn't approve of but the school may
not know about because the
the lunch program is is independent of
the school
um I mean I I visited a couple and they
had for their cafeteria they had people
come in and actually catering but see
part of the promise I see it is that
this is not the student that's free and
reduced
this is the student the family has the
wherewithal
to send the kids without the money
and then you're chasing this down
and and there's refusal to pay what is
representative cascad just to add to
that to me if there is somebody that is
stigmatizing a student then that's a
Personnel issue and it needs to be
addressed
any evaluation process I agree
representative Woodcock thank you Mr
chair just to refer to revenue hoggins
uh testimony
one of the statements he did say is you
could discern was that his concern had
been historically that some of the
younger youngsters in the cafeteria of
the gate in fact
and they would give them as they take
this home to Mary pick home your mom
tonight and give this letter so he can
square way of hand and that was his
concern you mentioned multiple times
over the last two or three years there's
a letter that they give the high school
kid prosecute them but the elementary
school is way in line take this home of
your mother because she needs she shows
us you know take care of it and I think
that was a concern he was thinking about
when he started talking about
stigmatization particularly and and they
thought that would be initially how it
may happen yeah however there is
follow-up from the food service director
or the person sure that is done
oftentimes up by phone is done by
internet internet but that's why he
wrote that in the in the bill with the
chair that they can't send it home by
the student that was the point that's
all I just recalling that directly thank
you represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um but the way I see it most of this
bill is is reasonably unobjectionable
but I'd like to call people's attention
beginning at line 12 and if you follow
along with me for a second I want to
demonstrate that this is not
particularly well worded any school that
participates in the national school
lunch breakfast program or national
school lunch program shall not provide
to any child who qualifies for a free
reduced breakfast or lunch an alternate
meal that is not provided to students
generally what is provided to students
generally a lot of schools have their
cafeteria they also have vendors that
come in I would argue and I think a lot
of other people might argue that the
vendors coming in are generally
providing food we're opening up a
situation because of the way this is
awarded after line 10 here that free and
reduced launch students could be
demanding whatever vendored food at
whatever cost and that could be
something that winds up being billed to
the school having to be covered by the
school that would have that language to
me would have to be cleaned up
considerably
thank you
represent dry you at here and yes thank
you Mr chairman
I'm glad you mentioned about
possibilities about how this might be
enacted because in this year's testimony
when we asked the sponsor
is this happening is this a current
issue he only talked about conjecture on
how it might happen and I didn't hear
any it's happening here today one he may
have said it in other years but he
thank you and that that goes on to what
I was trying to convey I am really
tired of hearing that schools
are doing something which is not good
for kids or that they're they're
insinuate are there's insinuation the
schools are mistreating so I don't
believe that the case I think teachers
and food service people are in there you
wouldn't be in that business to make
money you're there to help kids and I
think that's the genuine place that all
these people are at and for us to even
insinuate that you know their kids are
being uh intentionally stigmatized by
not providing a meal the best I'd like
to know where that's happening because
if that is I agree with representative
Cascada that's a Personnel issue
and somebody has to get on top of that
and say goodbye to that person
um
you know the the the the person is doing
that because that is not where we are as
a society today and I I'm sorry I just
can't believe that
our school districts are doing that
represent Balboni uh just a little
commentary my sister-in-law is a food
service director and I asked her to kind
of look at this and give me an idea of
whether or not these practices are
occurring in the district because she
works in and she's pretty strict about
what's allowed and what's not allowed
and she felt that it was a local school
issue and it wasn't
um prevalent in in her district and
again her bigger problem was uh dealing
with the the
parents who don't pay at the end and
most school districts absorb the cost at
the end can be significant and we never
treated Food Service as a money-making
venture
so thank you thank you
represent parano I just tried to check
my email I don't think I've received
anything from any constituents or
anybody in the state on this bill and
I'm wondering I can't remember how to
find the online testimony have and you
are all usually good at that Mr chair
yeah yeah I'll just do a little Maya
culpa two years ago this committee saw
this same bill
followed by a prime sponsor and
co-sponsored by Mullen Miler and luno it
left this committee itl 20 to nothing
um and I'm inclined to uh to do that
this year too
if that's uh
people can do whatever they want yeah
representative
um just a final to uh address line 12 13
14.
um
the food service has to offer a certain
meal
and from my experience what they call
like the Well when the wellness policy
came out you had to remove all vending
machines you couldn't have any more soda
and snacks all of that
which was bad
um
some I guess but I don't know if you're
thinking of there are alternatives kids
can buy and those are a la carte items
so there might be packaged snacks I
don't think there's Devil Dogs not
supposed to be and you know healthy
snacks from a vendor or vending company
which kids sometimes can just buy if
they bring the money but it's totally
separate from the hot lunch program kids
who have a debt have a right to the free
hot lunch but not to the you know the a
la carte stuff unless they got cash and
they're paying it on cash so I don't
know if that's that's what you were
thinking
thank you very much
there are a lot of Stories on soda
machines we used to call them pop
machines where I was in my pop machine
before all the rules came down and got
me eighteen thousand dollars annually
for the slush fund and then in Texas
where my daughter worked she couldn't
bring a Pepsi to school because they had
a contract with Coke you're right
exactly and that's that's that's where
we've gone with this some of this stuff
Money Maker though it's a money it's a
big money maker but it's not really the
way to go it's not really nutritious
we got the scoreboards too yes okay so
no more discussion on this we have a
motion of floor to itl this bill
um uh represent uh Madam clerk uh the
relative school lunch payment policies
so please call the roll Vice chairman
cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford
yes representative Belcher
yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortiello
yes representative Miler yes
representative Lane yes representative
Tanner yes representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
Heath yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
thank you
is that the consent yeah I would assume
so
great thank you uh the uh by the way I
don't think we'll do 654 today that's
the last one that was the bill we heard
first today and we had some questions
about monitoring and all that we may
want to you know
unless there's somebody would like to
move forward with it uh today I don't
know
we're no Russian right
we can take it up very shortly here you
know in the next you know a couple weeks
but okay 429 is the remaining bill for
today then oh wait wait a minute oh 170.
let's climb back up to 170 HP 170
requiring the teaching of cursive
representative leicus
is there a second
second represent four seconds the motion
did you have an amendment
yeah but I if you made the motion are
uh on the bill okay yeah
um
first regarding cursive we heard a lot
of testimony about how important that
was for brain development and
particularly kids with dyslexia and how
that helped them
um and then it's regards to math we keep
hearing there's a big drop off in how
kids do after a certain
time period hit
suddenly we have a big drop off and as a
math teacher that's when you really get
into having to do facts fractions
reducing fractions factoring all that
kind of stuff and that requires a good
knowledge memorization of those
multiplication tables and without them
it's it's a struggle and so if we're not
requiring them to be taught
and then suddenly you get to the math
skills that require those things you're
going to have a real drop off in in how
kids are doing and so I think we're
really hurting kids by not requiring
them yes they have calculators but
there's a lot of math that you do that
uh trying to use a calculator and not
just knowing it is going to take a long
further discussion from the second
yes thank you Mr chair I think that
students lose a lot in terms of
manual dexterity and things like that
which they then later need in doing
excuse me
I think students lose a lot in not
learning cursing and for that matter uh
multiplication uh they simply aren't
prepared to do a lot of the things
they're later very hard to do simply
filling out an application for a job or
for a driver's license or things like
that and just understanding what other
people have written whether or not they
themselves can do it it's important that
they know what it means and I think it's
a loss if we leave it out of school
okay
um
I'm going to ask you just hold on that
yes represent I I wanted to Echo what
representative Ford said one of the
things he said about being able to read
cursive so
as a former instructor where I graded a
lot of papers I myself uh
right would write comments it was the
comfortable way for me to think was to
have a paper a
a paper and write my comments
um not that I didn't know how to use the
you know doing it electronically I just
think differently and I write in cursive
because that would help me think a
certain way what I'm saying is you
students are going to be coming across
that where
um
they'll need to read not just students
it seems to me almost like another form
of illiteracy to be unable to read
cursive and I'm not just talking about
reading the Constitution the original
documents of the founding fathers I mean
certainly yeah that's great but you do
come across cursive so whether or not
you even
right in cursive which you know I think
the process of learning cursive from
what we've seen we've seen lots of
evidence that you
writing a cursive is good for you know
dyslexia but just in general I I firmly
believe it's similar to something that
happens when you do music lessons you
know I don't have my kids become you
know I didn't expect for them to start
playing an instrument in a Orchestra
professionally but I certainly had them
all do music lessons because I think
that's good for the brain from what I've
read learning to write in cursive is
good for the brain and I was half joking
uh the other day
about uh
the instruction
in uh I think Community College this
kind of gets to the multiplication table
part of this bill
and I was half joking thinking well
maybe we wouldn't have the problem of
needing remedial instruction in math and
Community College if we covered the
basics in grade school of memorizing the
so
grab somewhere thanks very much Mr chair
and and um I mean I think you you
probably know how a lot of a lot of a
lot of us feel about
telling school districts what to uh what
to teach
um but um but in in this case
um
you know especially you know when we're
talking fifth grade or below fifth grade
um you know when when when you don't
have you know you don't have students
sitting in study halls and stuff like
that this is um is coming in and you
know displacing something that's already
being taught so I think that's a concern
but I think ultimately though
um
is this is this a um a 28a
violation you know unfunded mandate
we're telling him to do something and
not paying for it there's no
appropriation with this bill
um
another question question to you on on I
would say no
um
teaching cursive has been taught for
years in schools and to say that we're
going to now have to put more money in
the budget so we can teach cursive uh
where you may have to put it as into the
heist of the higher education system so
it's taught the people are going to be
teachers
um
I see it as a component of language arts
it can be taught to students during when
you it is is spelling taught yes
spelling should be taught in school and
um McGraw-Hill used to have a wonderful
program with with the spelling and the
handwriting mixed together
you could see it you know in your new
words we're done in cursive uh I don't
believe that you're going to have to
have it's a 91a issue uh in an
elementary school the classroom teacher
is certainly qualified to be teach
handwriting you know I didn't say it was
28 days 28 days I'm talking about this
confidentiality going in a closed
session I'm sorry
getting in the other day but no I don't
think it is I'll just say no and I don't
think it is a 28-day issue
um in in the second part multiplication
tables those are are inclusive in the
the mathematics program right now
um whether they're taught to be
memorized or not
um it's just like how many people have
ever been in a spelling bee how many
people have ever been in the forensics
contest uh all those types of things you
do in schools
um you know that that's not doesn't take
a 28a to do that if geography be you
know you just you know it's taught
through the class of the homeroom
teacher because they're doing
but they're doing it now if Okay then if
they're not doing this then it's about
time they started doing this and
teaching the times tables or or having
kids memorize them and I understand all
kids won't and that's why you see part C
in this where you know or you will see
it in in terms of the amendment that I'm
going to introduce here and I haven't
had an opportunity to put that forth
where you need to have an opportunity
for you know those that have a you know
an IEP or a 504 plan or some reason
where they it's waived to the fact that
that's you know
not modified or account accommodated in
in those plans so
oh it's done so
at this point in time I like I would
like to offer uh this amendment and
that's zero two three three h
and you should assume excuse me that's
the old one
um
and and what it does it says each Public
School District and Charter Public
Schools shall provide instruction in
cursive writing
by the end of fifth grade as a component
of the English language arts and provide
the instructions multiplication tables
by the end of the fifth grade
and sub paragraphs A and B may be
accommodated modified or waived in
accordance with a student's IEP or 504
plan
yes
could cursive be taught as a second
language
occurs would be taught as a second
language in other words get money for
that but also aren't we aren't we
prescribing curriculum here and and
pedagogy and that's a local local issue
I mean it's I it's not that I don't
think I mean I know cursive and I know
multiplication and you know I memorized
them in school and I think that's great
but
um I think it's a local issue well I I'd
respond that of the states that just
recently put this in effect
Massachusetts is one our neighbors doing
it now that's in law down there along
with Alabama Arizona Arkansas Delaware
Florida Georgia Indiana Illinois
Kentucky Louisiana Maryland
Massachusetts Mississippi North Carolina
Ohio Oklahoma South Carolina Tennessee
Texas Virginia and West Virginia all are
thank you Mr chair
I share uh representative Tanner's
concern but more importantly the the
department that's currently going
through changes in their standards
bo6 is currently being reviewed
and these are the things that basically
outline to the school district in those
standards what needs to be done
academically
and so I don't know why the legislature
has to take on the responsibility
of doing this when in fact the
department for the last two years have
been working on standards for schools
and this clearly is a standard for for
schools I mean there's no question you
know we want students to be able to do
their multiplication tables now there's
no question about that it's whereas the
Aegis of the direction and to me it's in
those standards that are issued by the
department not not here
representative cordelli yeah thank you I
think that's right I think those 306
standards and we haven't even seen a
draft
um it hasn't gone to the State Board of
Education to not pass legislation
um waiting for something that might or
might not pass the State Board of
Education
um I think is not a wise move on our
part
ner
just to respond to representative
cordelli I'm not a curriculum specialist
you know I I don't I'm not I don't teach
this
the people who are creating the 306
standards are experts in the field
they are people who work in the schools
they know what the curriculum is I don't
know what the curriculum is
I'm not a specialist and I that's why
I'm I'm just hesitate I'm trying to
hesitate us to move forward and you're
you're absolutely correct the standards
are currently being reviewed by various
groups Etc the state the uh state board
of education is gonna soon I think this
month gonna see at least the draft of
them
it would seem to music after next month
or the next month well no I I understand
my understanding is supposed to be it's
ready Friday yeah so but anyway that's
that's my concern I'm not the expert
here and I'd rather leave it to those
who work in the schools to basically be
responsible for doing that
representative Cascade
you say that with a smirk I just you
know a number of public schools stands
306 and then you look at the academic
standards too which are two different
beasts right
um
I would not I don't think it's the
legislative's place to be
adding laws on instruction and
curriculum that's my first take I I
think that cursive handwriting should
absolutely part be part of minimum
standards and language arts curriculum
because cursive helps students with
dyslexia because they don't have to pick
up the pencil and form their letters
they can flow used to be a second grade
skill
it helps with reading fluency and
written composition so there is you know
scientific data that curse of
handwriting has
um
you know value for sure and I I
definitely am disappointed that it's not
being taught my nine-year-old's grandson
I bought him the polymer handwriting
book because he's not learning cursive
same for multiplication tables
when that was done in fourth and fifth
grade it helps to develop the brain in
being able to do rapid
thought process
but it doesn't belong here and I don't
think that's the root cause of the
problem
um I had the national Jamie vulner chart
that some somebody that testified in a
hearing since 2000 nationally we have
added 42 additional teaching tasks to
people
now you tell me has there been a law to
extend the school day because what
teachers have found is when we became
one-on-one you know technology that had
to start teaching keyboarding in first
second third grade because by fourth
grade
or even third grade some of their work
is all in word doc so they have to learn
those typing skills
but nothing was taken away from the
length of no time was added it was just
do it and so I'm suspecting that cursive
went on a back burner because they had
to do so many other things
plus instruction belongs with the
professionals it doesn't belong here
but it it should be in our Public
Schools I I don't disagree with that but
it's not our job to decide what
curriculum occurs at the local level
but again it's my biggest thing is is
the time factor and that's why it
doesn't happen okay
representative Belcher
thank you Mr Geo I just like to
highlight what I what I see is a a few
perhaps incongruent incongruities that
we've heard
um we've heard testimony we've heard
we've heard some opinions here that it
is not our place as a legislature to be
doing this that it should be the experts
who are doing this the experts reference
were those at the Department of
Education the Department of Education is
the executive branch at the state level
if they have the authority to dictate
this sort of thing down to the level of
the schools we absolutely have the
authority to tell the executive branch
representative cardelli and then
representative thank you just in terms
of curriculum
um last term uh we passed the
requirement for personal finance
in the schools overwhelmingly right
um the term before that we passed a
requirement to learn about the Holocaust
overwhelmingly in the house so
putting cursive into the statutes I
think is uh not much different than
those two uh Edition additions to the
school system
representative
just a comment don't you want less
honestly I the more and more I look at
this I can't see a specific curriculum
and I really hope that there are paper
that there's paper and pencils in the
school and that a teacher could maybe
draw on their own knowledge of how to
write in order to teach cursive you
don't even need a curriculum unless you
want to learn how to form the letters
correctly and I don't know about the
rest of you but at this point in time I
have so much scrap paper after all of
the stuff I've printed just in the month
of being on this committee that I have
found that I haven't needed that I could
contribute that to the schools and I
would hand write the multiplication
facts for them that's pretty simple I
don't think there's a curriculum it's
just paper and pencil we're talking
about
I I just you know I don't know why we
make these things anymore this is a
pencil by the way a pencil
um I carry a pencil with me all the time
because I'm constantly just you know
racing and I use more the other end of
it than to let it in or the graphite end
but in the other paper which I handed
out the importance of cursive
handwriting or typewriting for learning
in the classroom a high density EEG
study of 12 year old children and young
adults
on the first page it says we suggest
that children from an early age must be
exposed to handwriting and drawing
activities in school to establish the
neuronal oscillation patterns that are
beneficial for learning we conclude that
because of the benefits of sensory motor
integration due to the larger
involvement of the senses
as well as fine and precisely controlled
hand movements when writing by hand and
when drawing is vitally vital to
maintain both activities and a learning
environment to facilitate and optimize
learning
I don't see how this is going to be
adding something into our curriculum my
Lord I had it when I was in school and I
apparently faded away and because yes we
do have the keyboarding and all that
right now but also if you read this and
look at the neurological gains by doing
cursive
as opposed for example to taking notes
using your computer the long-term memory
of what you put down yes you can type
more than you can write
that's in this report but you also then
when it looks at the memory of what you
type versus what you wrote you will
learn you remember more that you hand
wrote than you will by keyboarding
so you know it's to me it's just you
know this is not adding a new curriculum
it's part of language arts uh and we've
added things like Unified sports we do
all kinds of things here you know and
adding things into our statutory
language but here we're doing we have an
opportunity to try to ensure that this
the skill is not lost
and and uh so I again I'll be quiet
thank you
um
I'm an expert I taught nine people how
to read write and do arithmetic it was
not hard to figure out that they needed
to learn cursive and that they needed to
learn multiplication not turning not
learning multiplication tables is the
same as not teaching them what the dot
line with two dots over it means you're
missing a fundamental part a building
block of this of this subject
just as a person on the street
I was appalled when I heard that they
were not teaching multiplication
tables in the school I couldn't believe
that that could possibly be going on so
I am again
have been wrestling with what do you
tell it to school to do what do you
allow the process to take do you do it
from the top down from the bottom up do
you go to a local school board first but
I think in this case
this is really part of something that's
been asked to be done and it isn't being
done and we're seeing we have the
benefit of the studies and see the
wisdom of this
we are making this
giving this to the Department of Ed and
the local schools to figure out how to
do it we're not prescribing a curriculum
people came and said it's not the
legislature's job to do curriculum this
isn't curriculum
this is this course of study we've we're
used to putting in course of study and I
have no problem with saying yes to this
because
Russell Woodcock thank you chairman
um I appreciate the fact that you
remember that you took out the part
about the memorization in terms of the
tables
um the fact that the Learned
multiplication uh and I do I do believe
a curse of handwriting are you looking
at right now huh
look at yours the 13 16 word it said
okay that's it yeah the multiplication
they're there just the word memorization
out the table so
um that being all said when I talk of my
send notes to my extra money
ten-year-old granddaughter I can't
figure out if she can't read cursive or
she just can't read my person
but considering my notes is probably
just my cursive but not hers is probably
fine that that being said I I I talk
with our superintendent our assistant
superintendent let's talk a couple of
people in our SAU uh and they are fusing
we are curse of the schools but beyond
all that I don't think it goes back to
the same thing we talked about we talked
about the immigration and naturalization
test and the yada yada yada I don't
think it's our place to put on local
schools what curriculum they have to
teach do we think this around this table
everything that's pretty important yeah
we should all do we all grew up with it
I think it's very important that being
said uh and people running out of
schools probably is really important to
suit it in where they can considering
all the other things they're going to do
but I don't think we should be
delegating or regulating local school
boys in terms of what curriculum they
have to write or how they have to do it
thank you representative Ford
I just thank you Mr chair I would just
like to add one other component to the
discussion
we now have through artificial
intelligence
the ability to have a program that
writes your essay for you
that cannot be be done in cursive
think about it
it's where you can get an honest thought
expressed on paper without being able to
push a button and have some other
machine
write your paper for you
it's a different world there
very different world
and I think it's important that we keep
as much as we can true to what it is
that all of us experience that was good
and I think this Falls in that category
you can't cheat in cursive you've got to
write it yourself
further discussion Mr chairman could you
clarify where we are from a
parliamentary procedure standpoint on on
what's being considered we've talked
about the bill
the amendment uh what is is been put
forward but it hasn't been made a motion
okay all right so that's where we would
be has the bill has the original Bill
been moved yes it has yes the original
bill was moved and through the
discussion we got into this
um I I did pass that around but I never
made the motion uh regarding that
particular
uh Amendment trying to get a feel I I
got the same feel I thought we would get
from this
um
so I'm going to make the motion right
now uh to on on this amendment I don't
have a copy of that from it's buried
under all the paperwork
what's the number of 360. I'd I'd make
the motion that we mend this bill at 03
16h
thank you
a second or second okay so we do have
that Amendment on the table right now
we've had some discussion regarding it
so
um it was second by represent
representative representative cordelli
either one
did you move the original
okay okay thank you
oh man moved originally yes yeah okay
yeah in fourth second is it and like
this amendment requires that shall be
shall both of those subjects shall be
provided in by the end of the fifth
grade
it doesn't say anything about Mastery or
anything such that it just says you
shall provide instruction
in these particular areas so
um
Mike
excuse me representative
I can't hear you over here yeah I'm
sorry
um whether memorization of
multiplication tables is now in there or
not in there because the heading says
cursive handwriting and memorization and
multiplication tables but then down when
it talks about multiplication the tables
it just says provide instruction of the
multiplication tables by the end of
fifth grade and what does that mean the
original said
um memorization of the multiplication
tables and the amendment just says
instruction of the multiplication tables
well just explaining how a
multiplication table when I went over
Amendment which I had which required the
provided instruction cursive writing and
in the second part encouraged the
instruction in what they did they
changed the one word encouraged to
provide in Part B there
and and use the
um the old amendment to move forward
where it would be you shall provide
instruction in both of these areas
um can we can we amend that back
in front of us right now what I know we
do I'm trying to figure out how to vote
on this amendment because part of the
point of this was memorization of
multiplication tables and that's not in
there
um
is this an early bill
and that's what is there any more
discussion on this bill
well that was my question on this
amendment we're going to go ahead and
vote on the amendment and vote your
hearts out my question didn't get
answered is having memorization of the
multiplication tables in the title mean
that that's what they're supposed to be
doing or just the fact that it says
provide instruction of take it out so is
it in or is it out this went through OLS
to have the you know the support of OLS
they wrote it up this way and when they
review they put it under the same area
category where we've always had curse of
handwriting and memorization of
multiplication tables uh so without they
just put it under the same title that
we've had there since this original bill
is put forth by Senator Stiles
and back then it was put forth as shall
and we changed it to encourage
and now you're now we're this this
amendment would change it to provide so
yes yeah I I kind of make one quick
comment all these sheets up here I'm
filling in cursive and I can't help see
the irony of that so if we want to find
like have clerks in the future might be
a good idea for yes kids to learn so
proceed okay
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis
no
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble
yes representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative miler yes representative
Lane yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative Cascade s
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years one nay
okay we can go to the next step and and
um yeah
um I make the motion to ought to pass as
amended
we otpa on as amended and that was
cordellia said the second I send them
any further discussion on that
none from the maker of the motion
not from the secondary
okay
representative
representative cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative Corey Taylor yes
representative Miler no
representative Lane no representative
Tanner no
representatively now no representative
Ellison no representative Wilcox no
representative Heath no representative
Balboni no Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
okay I make a motion to itl is there a
second
okay we have a motion made to itl made
by representative cascadden and second
what do I say although
so what you're going to have to do is
we're gonna have a fun time I wasn't
all right so if you're you're basically
you have the position this should not go
forward okay it should not go forward
because it is instructional practices
that is better placed and served in
minimum standards
versus a top-down mandate
I think it should be killed
that okay
and there was a second from and that's a
ditto yeah
further discussion I wasn't ready
represent Ford and then represent
Belcher
if this build
thank you
if we do not
encourage or require the teaching of
cursive
you will then require of every freshman
English student that they have a
calculator
that they must have one because they
won't be able to take out their pen and
write an essay in class
think about that
every one of you did it time and time
and time again I've assigned I don't
even know how many thousands
and if you say to every student you have
to show up with a device to take
freshman English
there'll be some students who can't show
up
I mean that's just when you get hung up
on that sort of thing you forget that
the technology and and
the Germans pin their pencil is
technology
and you've raised the standard quite a
lot and the cost quite a lot
you've also prevented the person from
creating an original document in writing
or submission for evaluation
and then you get the intrusion of
artificial intelligence
and so you're changing the very Niche
nature of teaching and learning writing
it's that transformative
I would think seriously about taking
writing out of your curriculum represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
clarify and be very clear that whether
this guideline were to be promulgated by
the Department of Education will arrest
as the legislature that is coming from
the level of the state going down onto
the the local districts and we being the
representative of the people are in the
Constitutional position to be doing this
disruption cordial I just want to
re-emphasize my belief that
if you cannot read cursive
you are somewhat illiterate it's a it's
another form of illiteracy
um as I said I had many
College freshmen and I would write very
neatly I'll add I have very good
penmanship
and I would write on their papers a lot
of comments
and
there were quite a few
who couldn't read them
so I would think seriously again as you
vote on this
um
I'll just leave it at that I have a lot
more to say but
I used to get a lot of red comments on
my spelling papers too
and
thanks
I'm sorry I've just remembered that was
one other thing I was gonna say I'm
sorry
go ahead
also to those like myself who in when I
taught I and I tried it both ways I
tried during especially the pandemic
when everything went
online and I couldn't I couldn't have
paper paper and while I would try doing
it the other way and it wasn't that I'm
technophobic at all I just thought
better and I thought I was providing my
students with better comments because my
brain would would think better to write
them in cursive in the margins of their
papers very copious notes about how to
make their papers better but if they
couldn't read them they could not
um
coming over here first and then then
yeah
thank you very much Mr chair just
comment on on process too when um when
executive departments create rules under
the uh the authority given to them by
the legislature
um you'll see on a number bills that
says uh the Department of Education is
granted rule making Authority Under 541a
um they will go ahead and make rules but
then those rules don't get promulgated
directly down to school districts they
have to come back to the legislature
through the joint
um legislative committee on
administrative rules uh which has
members of the House and Senate uh of uh
you know on it I the the total
membership may be
North at 10 less than 20. something like
that and um and they deliberate and uh
and and vote on the rules in Mesa and
oftentimes send those rules back uh they
also get legal advice from um uh from
the legislative services and the uh the
um uh the budget assistant on uh on
those rules and uh and sometimes with
Department of Justice as well so so I I
think to representative belcher's Point
um there are there is a process uh that
always runs uh what runs through the
legislature prior to
um our constituents being um being told
something to do specifically by the uh
executive branch
foreign
it's also for example when you have
attorney Merrill over there doing that
in gel car the first thing they're going
to do is look at the green book there
and say is this rule supported through
this this law if it's not then
hopefully the gel card refuses to accept
those rules and we've seen stuff come
through though oftentimes there is no
statutory authority to support so I
don't see gel car really as as our
oversight in they are to a degree but
they're the the oversight that I really
see that we have that we have to really
utilize is the legislative oversight
committee on Improvement and assessment
of Education
and that is a committee that needs to
get on top we've talked a little bit
today earlier just a few moments ago
regarding the 8306 rules uh which are
the minimum Public School standards for
public school the minimum standards for
public school approval and the academic
standards and
unfortunately a lot of the academic
standards were all pointing to are is
verbiage that's in what we call the old
Frameworks or guidelines
for instruction written back in 206 207
in that era which are totally obsolete
or really not even relevant to these
world
and I for one really am anxious to see
these new rules or new yeah the the 306
to see if they really are what they're
doing
and whether it's a
well I'd want to say too much more
whether those standards are also
reflective of what you know we need so
so Rick
um
and you bring up a I think a very
important point about our our commit our
public at Public Schools oversight
committee public education oversight
committee and um I'm just suggesting
maybe rather than taking this up on a on
a committee no recommendation and and
banging it out on the floor
um in two weeks that um that that if
there's no rush on on this thing or
maybe we want to retain this thing bring
it up talk about it at the the oversight
uh committee and bring it back bring it
back next year because right right now
obviously it we're split on um on this
and and maybe maybe retaining it having
it go to oversight committee taking a
look at the three that the um at the 306
rules the rule Draft when it does come
out and I mean maybe we're sort of
putting a cart before the horse in this
represent mile yeah on that on that note
I think I don't think anybody here is
disagreeing I'm not disagreeing with the
need for cursive or multiplication
tables absolutely not it's a it's a
procedural question that that I'm
concerned about and I think that's what
representative Luna was talking about
and that might be a way I mean I I hate
like heck to continue to put things off
Etc because we've got a hell of a lot of
stuff to do here but I think this might
be uh clarified if we have a little more
time to look at that because again as
I'm saying nobody's here saying that
cursive writing and multiplication are
bad it's a procedural question on what's
what should be who who should be
directing this I think and I think
perhaps we have a little more time that
might be clarified so that we could have
a
um
unanimous vote out of this committee
representative cordelli thank you I
believe that
um
going forward with this if it gets
passed we'll give the
um 306 group legislative
basis for putting that into the minimum
standards
otherwise they don't there is no
legislative basis and I think I don't
know if more discussion on this we've
discussed it quite a bit over the past
hearing and today I don't know if any
more discussion is going to change
things one way or the other and so I'm
I mean a simple phone call Fred ramonte
who's a coordinator of this thing whom
I've been in touch with on this would
would might be able to clarify that's
all I'm saying I mean they they may have
yes represent Tanner this um is already
in statute as a recommendation
what we're doing is changing it to a
requirement
um and therefore the the people that are
looking at the book and looking at what
we've already suggested
um in developing these standards I mean
it isn't like this is a brand new idea
to them
right yeah no it this is not a new idea
although we we have since net Senator
Nancy Stiles introduced this thing years
ago
we've we've had this this
split on on on the issue that
the curriculum and instruction is a
responsibility supposedly of the
um local
but then you look at the first Statute
in this yellow book right here
or the green one but I don't have
stickies in that one yet
um
21n colon 1. the general court finds
that students parents General citizensry
local teachers administrators local
government local school boards school
administrative units and state
government have a joint and share
responsibility for the quality of
Education delivered through the public
education system in the state of New
Hampshire
getting you know I
sometimes we say that the local has this
response but I think it says joint and
shared responsibility
and if if we as legislators are
contacted by people of those groups we
have a responsibility to move forward
with legislation
um I know we can wait for the executive
branch to tell us how we're going to do
things
um I'm I'm not there I'm in the
legislative branch
and for for that reason and when I hear
and what I see and when I see people
holding their pencils I don't even know
how they're doing it like that I just
can't even grasp it and and and and and
unable and when I have a grandkid come
home and say I'm really not can you
manuscript it Papa instead of you know
in your whatever you're doing I was
basically doing the old zaner blowser
type or a half breed of it maybe a
little Palmer method in there and I was
writing and and so that that's a little
scary to me I I think we're we're losing
something that's very valuable and we
know neurologically it's very important
too and the brain does get developed so
I I agree I I I have a distaste for
sending as an education committee a bill
that's basically some are going to see
is so simple
um to the floor with a 10 10 vote
and we're going to send spend a lot of
time debating this thing and that's not
the way it should be done I agree
so I I don't really have a good answer
on that right now yeah if we retain it
you know we've retained you know this
kind
you know this whole thing for years you
know when I first came to my caucus and
I came with a bill saying yeah I I think
the curse of writing is really important
and let's just leave the multiplication
at a courage multiplication facts
because there is a debate going on in
that right in stemming out of California
where there's two ways of teaching
mathematics and and I agree
wholeheartedly with parts of one and all
of the other
um and so I there's change going on in
our country but I I don't think I have
in my own thinking room for change that
we shouldn't be teaching cursive right
we need to be teaching cursive
and so in in providing instruction it
doesn't say anything about memorizing it
it just says provide instruction
and it's it's it's not it's almost a
step up from
encourage it's it's it's not saying well
you're going to have to have this before
you're going to get in sixth grade
uh so I yeah I don't know if retain is
going to do it unless we can really
actually sit down and try to come to
some kind of a constructive positive end
on this thing yeah so so Rick just as a
sort of like Point Counterpoint on this
I I I I I hear what you're saying
um and I agree that I think this is
going to be a prolonged I mean if this
comes out no recommendation this is
going to be a prolonged
thing on the floor
um this is while it's important I think
I think Mel said it really well that
that none of us are disagreeing that
that cursive is important that
multiplication table is important I
think there's a lot of
elements to curriculum that are that are
important for our kids to be um to be
learning
um but also I think I think you know
people in New Hampshire are expecting a
lot out of this legislature and we've
got really you know big issues to to
tackle and uh and we will be taking up
big issues on the on the floor of the
house I hate for this to be one of those
ones that just gets right in the middle
of it and puts the takes if we go back
several years ago when we we look at the
the teaching history and Civics our
government that's in our statute you'll
notice there's a portion there where it
lists some topics Within
those topics were put in there by
Senator dalessandro myself
and there are some things we believed in
jointly together but we were just at
that point we were in parting to
the doe these are topics which will be
included Within These subscribers you
know yeah you're you're taught the
Constitutional United States you you
learn about the free market all that
types that's in our in our laws
getting down into the micro into the
weeds
um
we didn't feel there's any need to go
there that that's the local
responsibility
what you teach and how you teach and all
that so I think there is room for us as
an executive branch to teach some of the
broad areas and this is just one of
those broad areas within language arts
English language arts
so I I don't know I unless we can really
you know keep go somewhere on that one
we'll probably end up having a debate on
the floor
and that I don't look forward to right
because that is not going to be a
constructive thing for the people of the
state to see us on the floor arguing
yeah so
I guess that you know um
I I don't want to have to be there I I
think that's you know as chair education
I I think that would be a real wrong
thing to do and we need to hammer this
thing out in this committee and if we're
not prepared to go out and having a big
fight on the floor and that's what it'll
be
the the
ugly then then why not retain it why why
not retain it and and I'm willing to
keep this here without retaining it for
you know several weeks and if we can
work something out fine but
um by March 16th we better have
something on this one well let's let's
let's keep it for a few weeks if we
can't uh do something then we're going
to have to vote it
um either no recommendation or retain it
but yeah but but I I give it a little
bit of time sure
Mr chair represent represent cordelli
had us up first thank you
um I'm hearing a lot of agreement that
the schools should be doing this
represent my life yeah I just uh I just
emailed Fred vermonte to probably get
some background of where we are with
this if it's there even so just for the
information the committee yeah I know
Fred
yeah
perhaps in Belcher thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to try to speak to the
process for a moment and I would like to
put forward that whichever way we go
with it we are in fact resolving the
situation one way or the other if we
would decide to go ahead with a vote we
are sending a message and we're
resolving that as a legislative branch
we have the ability to get this done and
move forward with it if we were to
decide to retain it we are also
resolving it in favor of
so effectively subordinating ourselves
to the rule-making authority that we
already delegated to the executive
branch and I think that Beyond more than
just being the education committee which
is huge we also have a responsibility to
zealously guard the powers do this
okay so what what I'm going to do is I
am going to not act on it any further
today we're going to leave it right
there so it's not out of our committee
but I'm letting everybody know it will
come out of this committee if we can't
get some resolution by March 16th
and so I I think that we can do it I'm
going to be positive and think we can do
this area of learning so yeah there is a
motion
um right on the table of itl probably
complete that vote
well can't we just withdraw it well but
then we're then we're left with a with
only one
um right but if we go ahead with the itl
then we've completed the whole process
I think I think I may I think what
chairman is saying we're just going to
hold on it the thing that's on the floor
right now is the ital motion when we
come back to consider it that's the
first thing that needs to be considered
along with whatever other information
that is correct I've I've done this in
past years
you know even closer to getting into the
vote throwing the old gavel down said
that's it guys we're done
and and we all would go on caucus we'd
come back with calmer heads
um I think that can be done so we're
going to just leave it right where we
are right now
and called a day on this particular Bill
one more question Mr chair just on the
process on that so
um I just want to make sure that the
fact that we've already taken a vote
on this doesn't and and and once we
close the exact session uh although if
you're recess
please this will be recessed to a time
to be determined okay and that and that
um the court the the house clerk will
not
we'll we'll accept that that this is
still in committee that will be written
down at this point down at recess right
okay and still into the announced okay
great thanks so we're going to the green
sheets okay all right thanks thanks
so folks this uh concludes oh we do have
oh shippers we have one more bill 429.
[Laughter]
exact session
yeah anything that comes to you of
course but
okay we have HB 429 FN
requiring the offering of breakfast and
lunch in all public and Charter Public
Schools
ah
did I suggest we all stand up and
I think that's a good good thought
let's take uh let's take a few minutes
please
thank you Hal all right
429. I know I got that
this is a early bill
yeah stay warm make sure you're yeah
we'll take five minutes next bill is an
so
these records so I got it all good there
and everybody's good with that makes
sense
I mean I could rewrite it yeah but you
HB 429 this Bill requiring the offering
of breakfast and lunch in all public and
Charter Public Schools
okay 429 FN
represent dry do you have a motion yes I
move itl
is there a second second represent
Belcher seconds
discussion from represent dry yes thank
you Mr chairman
first of all I want to make sure that
we're working off the same page I have a
a fiscal note and that came that's not
the same that was in the original bill
is that what we're all working on all
right because this had different numbers
from the original one what what what's
the LBA number on your fiscal note uh
23-0341
same thing yeah and revised on 2 1 23.
I think that this was one that was sent
to us by on the email
okay it is oh three four one two one
so are we all working off the same page
are the people that don't some may not
have this
um
um the difference is the numbers and the
fiscal report uh and the back so it's
yeah I can do that I
uh there are a couple other changes but
it's it went to saying the number of
schools in New Hampshire operating the
nslp is 5 456 which is the same as the
last page
number of schools in New Hampshire
operating nslp but not the breakfast
program 27 number of New Hampshire
public charter schools not operating
either program 34 rather than 43 before
and the number of New Hampshire Public
Schools not operating either breakfast
or lunch six the previous one said 153.
so it's a big difference okay so we went
with this a little bit last time so the
reason I'm uh let's get the other change
too okay um on the estimated increase
up top on the on on the front side there
you'll see in the old one it said 331
thousand dollars
194 000 in the new one one at least one
ninth it says at least 194. yeah at
least
194 thousand dollars
for fy25
at least 196
000 opposed to a three hundred thirty
four thousand dollars on the initial
and on 2026 at least two hundred two
thousand dollars opposed to 343 thousand
dollars
those have changed yep
Mr chair yes
um
unless you were looking for more uh no
no no okay thank you so so what I have
to say has to do with this and the first
is
um that
again it's not accurate because the
public charter schools were going to be
I have I have an amendment okay so this
one still talks about it as if they were
in it so it's been it's difficult to
work off a sheep that you know probably
might be changed but
um
this we have never found out what the
six schools that do not offer do not
participate in either National program
are doing are they successful fine uh do
we need to make them a waiver because
this requires all the schools to be in
that program
I don't think that we know yet enough to
make to make that decision of the 27
schools that do lunch the lunch program
but not the breakfast program
again we don't know why they haven't
included the breakfast program they will
be forced to be include the breakfast
program we do not know if that involves
Staffing
facilities
or anything else that belongs with
running a program so it's very little
information to make a decision on and
456 plus 27 plus 6 is very close to 500
9 about 95 percent of the schools are
already doing the breast press program
we're looking at a mandate
for about five percent of the schools
okay as the second I'm sorry
yeah yeah thank you Mr chair
um and just just to further add on to
that and I can't comment on an amendment
right now because what I have is the
bill here in front of me and the if you
the motion is itl so the bill as written
as as I'm looking at it the number of
schools that don't currently offer any
breakfast or lunch program here I
believe is
34.
of that at least some of these and I've
heard personally from them their very
existence would be threatened by this
bill because they don't have the ability
to just simply add the facilities
necessary to offer these things on site
some of them are currently doing other
things bringing in food via third party
and whatnot
the second thing I would say is I don't
know why we would take away the local
Choice from these schools who are doing
things right now that suit them we've
heard testimony previously about school
bus schedules if we make them have this
this lunch Pro or I'm sorry this
breakfast program come in are we going
to have to change up bus schedules are
we going to have to have this supervised
so we're going to have to renegotiate
contracts around this there's a whole
bunch of stuff Beyond just what's
obvious that this bill introduces which
is why I believe we should idealism
yeah
okay further discussion representative
Allison were you going to discuss
something yeah I was going to discuss my
Amendment but it's not on the floor yet
so I will not discuss it yeah
yeah
representative yeah I understand that
the motion is not on the floor
but would it behoove the committee to
know the contents of that
because it's going to be a direct
assembly direct answer to both the maker
and the seconder of the motion as it
relates to it so it's a procedural issue
of Mr chair that just to have him
indicate what he plans to do with the
Amendment that would change the original
motion
well I don't know if it'll change it but
but it is it's referencing and
concerning that motion so he can go
ahead and speak and and and address what
he would have done with that Amendment
yes
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative uh the amendment does
three major things of one that pulls
Charters out of of the bill it would not
relate to Charter Schools two it changes
the effective date to 2th of July 1
2024 instead of 23 and it provides a
waiver process for school districts who
do not participate in the federal
pre-orduce price lunch program and they
can request a waiver from the Department
of Education to that as long as they
meet the nutritional guidelines and the
free and reduced price uh lunch income
guidelines for whatever program they're
offering those are the three major and
just to be clear I I think that the
numbers the numbers are clear that we're
really talking about the 27 schools that
don't provide breakfast but do provide
lunch in the six who provide neither uh
just an additional piece I have the uh
autistical update from the Department of
Education that I got yesterday which I
would distribute as part the it's part
of the amendment as well which kind of
talks about money and how much the
department would spend uh would have to
spend that number keeps coming down and
down and down and down because you're
absolutely right we started at 156
schools and now we're down to 27 27 and
uh and six so that's my intention with
if I have the opportunity to offer the
amendment
perhaps Sam McDonald a question for
representative Ellison about the
amendment so schools that use the waiver
that would be allowed would they be
waving out of the federal program but
still be mandated to have provide
breakfast for other means or are they
waving out of providing breakfast
entirely because they may not be able to
they would be covered the first part of
it would be have to be providing
Brentwood lunch and breakfast and you
can't wave out of that but you can wave
out of the other parts of it thank you
represent Belgium
thank you Mr chair justice so just to
speak in addition to the what we've just
heard about the amendment
I certainly can appreciate the idea that
Charter Schools would come out of it and
that would solve one problem however I
think ultimately we just heard is that
the amendment in effect
would simply Force the schools to ask
permission and then add administrative
process to maintain the status quo
further discussion representative Damon
thank you Mr chair responding to
representative Belcher
they would be maintaining a status quo
in terms of the way that they obtain
meals to be served but they would be
expanding the meal service
because these are the schools that
either don't have
breakfast and lunch or don't have
breakfast so it's not status quo
well if maybe I'm sorry I wasn't clear
what I meant what I meant by that is the
status quo being if they currently are
not part of that program they don't have
to be part of that program if they are
asked permission or given permission and
then go through the administrative
process to maintain that status so they
could wind up just right where they're
yes representative Ray thank you Mr
chairman so I'm curious if we know
anything about the 27 schools because
there's a big difference between yes we
have the facilities we just haven't
chosen to do it and no we need facility
you guys know my favorite statute
28a if we're mandating that they provide
breakfast and we're not providing funds
because the funds here were not to cover
those all those facilities and the
renegotiation with staff and all of the
other stuff that's going to be required
we did hear some of the schools the
buses are just barely getting in there
it by the Bell as it is they don't have
staff on in the mornings you know the
cafeteria staff so now you have to
expand that that costs money we're
telling them they have to do it we're
representative cordelli and then
representative thank you for those
schools that aren't currently providing
breakfast would there be
um contract negotiations involved to
make sure that those teachers were there
earlier to cover
um those students arriving for
senator cascad
um question that I'm just not sure of
because the fiscal impact is local so
I'm going to put my taxpayer hat on for
a minute
what what kind of a dollar amount would
we be expected for local school
districts to add to their budgets
because if there's a cost and I just
want an idea because
then there's a choice of cutting
something over something else just
curious I don't know I don't know what
the local cost would be but
curious Justin Allison you have anything
I we sort of asked that question and
nobody knows the answer to it uh the
assumption that it may be an assumption
under this legislation is that the state
would pick up the costs for these
additional parts of the bill
okay represent Tanner
so care Sarge high school at least no
one no one
um lives close enough to walk to school
so everybody's either bussed in or they
drive themselves in and when the
breakfast program was first uh proposed
you know that was one what you said was
one of the problems that some of the
buses arrive and the kids have maybe
five minutes to go to their lockers and
get to the you know homeroom or whatever
the first period class is and what they
did was they did a grab and go
um to solve that problem and the cat at
least the person who runs the cafeteria
is always there at the very beginning of
school anyway and had been right from
the beginning so the grab and go was
made the night before
and the kids just came down checked it
further discussion
yes
thank you Mr chairman
that's a good point
um I would like to know maybe
if we pay for
some schools now to put this into
process
do we need do we owe anything to those
who've already been doing it already
um
uh Woodcock Hey general I mean there are
schools that sell breakfast and have the
staff there all but 37 in the whole
state and and they're they're making
money in their in their their food
service program that's why they're in
business they keep it at least we break
even running luck
um I think the bigger 10 here is is
the simple goal of this is to get the 34
schools in the state
offering 33 through what 33. thank you
33 schools in the state
I thought it was the 27th okay the 27
schools the 27th school in the state the
goal here to get those schools providing
two meals a day that's the goal we all
talked about cursive writing well hell I
can't I'm starving to death I'm not
talking about cursive writing I haven't
eaten since last night's supper I mean
come on folks this all this is a very
basic stuff giving the kids the
opportunity to have a bottle of milk for
juice and in a bar or something and
they're on the way we are talking about
homemade waffles here we're talking
about grab go get something to eat get
your brain going so the rest of your the
day is not wasted this is a simple help
and everybody stays pretty much doing it
except for 34 schools to give those
schools the opportunity
um to do that that's all this is very
simple thank you Mr chair are any of
those 34 schools uh you you talk about
place the 27 but go ahead or 27. Mommy
look great machine correct you tell him
are any of those schools
you figured the number up providing any
kind of
nourishment for the kids at all in the
morning
as far as we know on record just lunch
just lunch I would not be surprised
knowing all the schools as you do to get
kids at something there but but it's not
required so it doesn't have to be
reps in Belcher thank you Mr chair I
I've heard a couple times grab and go
and I want I want to clarify where
exactly are they going after they grab
are we are we are they going to class
where they're now eating and drinking
are they sitting in front of a computer
where they're typing and eating and
drinking are is this interfering with
what they're doing I don't
know happens in Kearsarge um yeah they
cut they there's usually one only one
bus maybe uh that shows up that late
maybe two and you're talking about maybe
60 students so maybe one or two in your
class are in that position and uh if
they have a regular class rather than a
study hall or
um you know I I taught physical
education so they would come down in the
gym they'd eat their stuff in the locker
room or whatever and then come out you
know and and work in the gym but they uh
other teachers allowed one or two you
know it's only one or two students and
everybody will you know let them go to
the back of the room and and eat their
stuff so
thank you
representative
computers
if these six schools that aren't are not
providing breakfast or lunch do we have
any idea how many what the number of
students would be from those schools
that who would meet the federal income
eligibility for
I'm sorry it just says it doesn't say
they aren't doing it just says they're
not operating in the National two
national programs
we don't really know exactly how they're
doing it
oh right but we don't know whether or
not they're calculating
if the students meet the income
eligibility yeah they may be doing both
meals but not
in the National program right so they
might not be capturing those numbers
that we need for the free and reduced
Aid
um
right
no right so that's what I'm getting at
is the numbers that we need to calculate
it's the 27th the school the six the six
are doing something but they're not
following and some schools have their
own program their own standards and then
they have the waivers to do that that's
so those those folks are eating but
we're talking about the 37 schools
27 thank you Margaret the 27 schools
one so we know that free and reduced
feeling yeah
not participating in the program right
can program
well I'm getting confused here we know
all the kids in this state that are
qualifying for free and reduced yes
yes but we supposedly are supposed to
know them all yeah
hypothetically but then so my question
would be if they're
if they're not operating either of the
programs are those that are free and
reduced
getting whatever program is being used
by it free and reduced other words are
are they paying are they not paying do
but we're going to collect the free and
reduce from them
represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair I just want to say
that it sounds like we're in agreement
that we don't want students to be hungry
and we don't want students to starve but
really at what cost to the rest of
academics is really the concern that
some of us in the room share if we're
hurting students in other ways by taking
funds to direct to one program when we
don't know what the schools are already
doing it seems like that we're unsure
with these six schools with these 27
schools what other plans are in place
and if they don't have a planning place
as to why so it's irresponsible of us to
move this forward not knowing the whole
facts and how else we could be hurting
students and hurting our schools and I
just don't think we should move forward
with something we keep saying we keep
asking questions and the answer is well
I don't know nobody knows we don't have
Jefferson Allison uh it gets in response
to that we pass bills all the time here
on policy and they go to finance and
finance decides how much it's going to
cost and sometimes it's fifty thousand
dollars sometimes it's 150 million
dollars but we don't get into
degenerating what that number is and
Brooks and Lucas then represent Damon
um the comment was made about just two
or three kids but I'm noticing that it
says all
every pupil under its jurisdiction
they'll be paying for those
that are free and reduced but they have
to make it available to every student
under their jurisdiction I can tell you
by golly if I could have gotten those
extra five minutes to not eat breakfast
before I got on the bus and to eat them
at school
that would have been me no I'll get to
the school you haven't eaten I've been
great
I did eat but
thank you Mr chair
I just really want people to reflect if
you've ever had an experience being
hungry
for let's say 24 hours how your brain
works or doesn't work
how your mood is how your impulse
being fed is important breakfast is
particularly important the word actually
means break fast as in most people
didn't eat after a certain time in the
evening for the longest interval of
their 24-hour day we need to feed kids
this isn't that complicated
I don't perceive it as a lot of money
for the value that it has
and I would really strongly encourage
people to appreciate our privilege that
most of us are not hungry
and make it so these kids aren't hungry
I have no objection to feeding to making
sure kids are not hungry it's the how we
do it is the question not that that it
needs to be done and since
we don't know whether these schools are
providing for the kids who don't eat at
home we don't know how much why they're
not participating in the the state I
mean the federal program we don't know
that they're not providing just that
they're not participating in the federal
program
we don't know
um
what extraneous circumstances they may
have that we're now forcing them to do
so we're not going to know how much it's
going to cost them as a local school
district that now you're saying oh but
we'll cover it but that's not in here
we don't know and and so how can we tell
them they have to do it this way as
opposed to some other way when we don't
even know what this way is
foreign
thank you
um so six schools we know are not
operating in this National School
breakfast program or the lunch program
yes
so they might be feeding their kids
um likewise the 27 we know they're not
in the school breakfast program but we
don't know that they're not providing
them some kind of breakfast either
so there's a heck of a lot we don't know
and we're going to mandate things on
um the Department of Education and the
local school districts based on things
we don't know
representative cordelli I'm represent
Woodcock thank you we do know
provincelli that these schools are
eligible for free reduced lunch
we do know that they're prying students
who are eligible for free reduced lunch
we do know that and we do know all this
that students are eligible for free and
reduced lunch I'm not having any option
to receive a free reduced breakfast even
though they're eligible for it because
these schools are not providing
opportunity for students to get the
breakfast although they qualify for the
breakfast and they are doing the lunch
because they qualify for lunch
all we're trying to do is get schools
that qualify for free and reduced lunch
and breakfast to provide that for the
youngsters just 34 schools doing that
that's what we do know so we do know
they're not doing it we do know but they
they are going to do it for life so it's
not like they are doing it they're just
not doing breakfast and that's always
saying do breakfast
it's not your day with some brain food
but what we don't know
is whether those schools that are not
participating in front aren't providing
some kind of a nutrition to the kids in
the morning well we know that well
that's true we don't know what they
aren't providing we don't know what any
school isn't providing nor do we know
what they are providing but we do know
they are providing in accordance with
well that that might be question two you
know a contractor could provide or even
surpass the National Standard
represent Tanner
I think you don't let the perfect be the
enemy of the good in this situation
before we had uh breakfast at Pierce
Arch
um I was providing breakfast the nurse
was providing breakfast I think we had
some soda machines in the back hall uh
kids were drinking soda for breakfast
um and
you know I just
um I we can argue over this and you can
pick up we don't know this and we don't
know that we don't know this but we do
know the kids do need food and we do
know that if we do this we'll we'll find
those answers and at the same time we'll
give some benefit to students so please
don't let the the perfect perfect be the
the bill does not say make sure that
kids who don't have breakfast are
getting breakfast
it says that they'll be providing during
school hours
breakfast I mean the that it will be
available during school hours to every
pupil under its jurisdiction which is a
huge thing very different than providing
we're talking we keep thinking of those
kids who aren't eating at home because
they can't they you know don't have it
available or whatever that's not what
this is even saying
asking to be done they're asking that
each school provides
makes available to every student in the
school whether they can eat breakfast at
home or not
and that's why I was saying as I could
eat breakfast at home but I wouldn't
have I would have availed myself of this
but these schools these 27 we don't know
that they're not providing breakfast
to those kids who need it they're not
providing breakfast according using the
federal program and they may have
determined that it costs them more
because they have to follow all those
guidelines which might be hiring extra
helpers or whatever they have to do
as opposed to just doing a grab-and-go
we don't know that they're not doing a
grab and go we don't know that this is
even needed
but we know that we're expanding
breakfast by doing this to all schools
to all students which is very different
than providing for kids who can't who
don't have access to food
foreign
so the the next step is could be if
we're required to do this we've had
bills in here before telling us how many
minutes we must require for the serving
of lunch
not including the time going to the gym
or to the cafeteria and coming back from
the cafeteria
are we then going to have a similar
thing occurring for breakfast
where you have to have so many minutes
for a sit-down time to have breakfast
and my concern on that would be while
we're really now starting a Whittle into
the academic time that we have available
for instruction and and the days are
already compared to other countries in
this world very short
maybe that could be an unintended
consequence but maybe it never will
happen but we've had legislation come
represent uh Damon
thank you Mr chair
I want to clarify that the bill does not
say that breakfast and lunch will be
free to every people it says they will
be served without cost or Roost trust to
any child who meets Federal Income
eligibility guidelines schools can and
do charge for the meals for other
students so we're not giving it all away
and frankly if it takes a little more
time they'll learn faster after they're
fed
represent Belcher yes a very quick note
um sometimes kids don't make the best of
decisions I was certainly guilty the
only way to make sure a kid doesn't have
a soda for breakfast would be to remove
vending machines from schools and even
that might not totally do the trick but
there's nothing in that bill that that
would do that
if they haven't they have to turn them
off
Federal program says you have to have
those things turned off
and that took a long time for a lot of
people who are getting money from these
machines to really get it
perhaps and dry
thank you Mr chairman how can we find
this is an early bill
um so if we have to have by the 16th of
this month get this out so I don't know
if we're unless uh Rambo or somebody
over there at the department has this
information
um
I don't know I don't think there's going
to be time available right now we're
really squeezed for time now we're gonna
have to act on this one right off we
can't put early bills off
can we make phone calls
on a Friday afternoon 410 you're not
going to go
not now I mean before the 15th I no
because then we have to repost this
thing in the calendar and nope not gonna
happen
inside of the fact of 456 schools
already do it so I like to get to figure
out how to do this it's not like 34
can't figure this out because they are
they already do it they already are
doing that
um the school schedule is going to be
figured out because 456 out of almost
500 are already doing it it's not that
hard I was just giving those kids an
opportunity it's as simple as that
simple as that
further discussion
not seeing any
we're ready for the amendment the motion
no not yet so personal voting this is
not the number representative
chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative coreyello yes
representative Myler no representative
Lane no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock new
representative Heath no representative
Balboni no Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes
10 years 10 days oh Mr chair
I will move out to pass on this bill is
there a second second
uh Ellison makes the motion and I have
him in Woodcock makes the second this or
and it's uh I was to pass I have an
amendment as well
we gotta you know get her getting
squared away I understand when we get to
okay so we're into that uh uh maker the
motion do you have
a comment
uh yes I I think this bill this bill is
a small step of an important step in
feeding kids in the State uh for me it's
a no-brainer uh what comes through the
literature or you see it everywhere is
you know you can't learn Calculus if
you're hungry
and you just put in whatever you want in
there you can't learn social studies if
you're hungry so I feel very strongly
this is an important bill in general
point
thank you thank you any discussion from
the maker the second yes I would uh I
would remind representative Ford
representative Lucas well Paul is not
here we spent hours of summer hours
hearing testimony all in support of
feeding students ours in the need for
this
this bill expanded that we heard it all
so there's only we don't know is there
thank you
reference Ellison do you have an emotion
Al 2023-0170h
[Music]
can you say that a little slower please
-017
-0 h
and that's being distributed I'm also
Distributing the the most recent
Collective system we've also recent uh
it's going backstabing from the
Department on this that we've got
yesterday we'll cancel it as well
representative
do you have any more is there any more
coming around I've got some more coming
here okay
foreign
[Music]
Woodcock on both
you you did the second on on the
amendment as well okay I was just trying
to make sure we had it all down right
yeah
okay
um would you like to go through this and
take us through the numbers here please
in terms of the amendment itself uh I
mentioned this earlier but it basically
includes charter schools for the bill uh
changes in the effective date to July 1
2024 and it puts a waiver provision in
for school districts that might want to
run their programs their own program
as long as they meet the two
requirements
Federal breakfast and lunch program one
is the influential guidelines and two
the income guidelines we did try to dig
around and see how many school districts
the state doesn't answer this question
about which six districts aren't doing
this but we found out that that Handler
runs its own program okay it will runs
its own program but they do meet all
that they meet the requirements but
there they do not participate in this
program I guess at some point
Londonderry was there but I think that
was changed uh but that is that's all
the individual information we could get
on individual school districts
okay it's a number one uh
so it it cleans it up and sense of you
know going forward uh what we we talked
about at Charter School uh directors
about issues and providing meals and
those programs are all over the lot some
are having everything brought in some
have few have kitchens they're doing
their own most of them are contracted or
lunches some for breakfast uh and in
that full issue around Charters and
feeding students needs a lot more
sort of research and discussion you can
think that we would go forward with in
the next year because we have so bad as
what
um my goal in filing the bill
uh filing the amendment is to feed more
further discussion
uh do you have anything to say in the
second reps of Woodcock no sir thank you
representative Lucas
foreign first I wanted to make it clear
that I did eat breakfast
even though I would have taken advantage
of the school breakfast I did eat
breakfast
um
I'm looking at the assumptions a number
of things the assumptions on the
um
the fiscal note is basically any school
not operating the SBP is not serving
breakfast
we have no idea if that's true or not
any school not operating the nslp is not
serving lunch we know that's not true
Londonderry did
decided not to participate in in the
federal lunch program because the kids
weren't eating the food and they were
throwing it away
and so they decided they weren't going
to do that they weren't going to take
the federal money they were going to
provide their own stuff
they are providing food kids are eating
lunch and they're much happier
so that's an incorrect assumption
um
and then downward talks about
um the money yeah they made an estimate
of the money but that's for the state
implementation that has nothing to do
with the locals so it's still
um an unfunded mandate because there's
no money in here for the towns and the
additional cost to provide breakfast
make it available to every student in
the school as opposed to just those who
are going hungry
it's that number is just what the doe
and whoever
people departments in the state have to
deal with running the this program it's
not how much it costs these local
schools
um
I think there was one more thing that
I'm not seeing it right now
um
I guess you know the fact that we're
mandating now that every school
provides lunch to every student and oh I
know what it was well you're assuming
that well they're going to make money
and it's going to come back but didn't
we just have a discussion about school a
school lunch programs running in the red
and having problems collecting the money
and all of that wasn't that one of our
bills that we just talked about
so
you know we can't even make that
assumption that because we're selling
lunch
now it's going to pay for itself
when we already know there's an issue in
some schools that their programs are
running in the red so now we're going to
ask them to run in the red more I mean I
am very much for making sure kids have
food
I am very much for having the local the
school approach some one of the local
um
what Farms
well Farms or or
um other local facilities that provide
breakfast and donating
breakfasts for those kids who aren't
eating breakfast and maybe that's what
these kids these schools these 27 are
doing we don't know
I love voluntary you know feeding of
kids but mandating not just feeding the
kids who aren't eating but feeding the
kids who are eating which is what we're
mandating here
it uh represent Belcher thank you Mr
chair just to follow up on reply us and
the the idea that we have an unfunded
mandate here I'd like to look at the
waiver procedure here for a moment
so we can grant a waiver to a school to
not have to participate in national
school lunch program or whether the
school breakfast program
um to implement its own policy but that
policy still must comply with the income
guidelines and still must provide free
and reduced priced lunch and breakfast
so
if they're not being reimbursed by the
federal government because they're not a
part of the program and we've given them
a waiver for it but they're still
providing that for free where is the
money coming from because we're not
providing it that sounds like an
unfunded mandate
further further questions from the
committee
yes representative Woodcock thank you
not a question just a reference to
Senate uh like this the first two
assumptions that you said are incorrect
they're they're just they're just
overarching assumptions at least they're
not incorrect a school operating the SBP
did not serve any breakfast that's not
an assumption that's a fact the school
law operating a life is not serving
lunch that's a pretty simple fact you're
not serving you're not serving that
that's something to base the rest of the
stuff on so they aren't incorrect
assumptions
thank you
for a further question yes
representative McDonald I appreciate you
saying that representative Woodcock but
I would like to counter that because as
it says on this fiscal note that was
updated and provided to all of us the
National School breakfast program is the
acronym SBP and the first assumption is
any school not operating the national
breakfast program is not serving
breakfast so therefore maybe they're
operating in a way that's not federally
regulated you mentioned that maybe the
Londonderry school did that at some
point or maybe Hanover does that now so
that is not a correct assumption to make
so that would say that there's an
inaccuracy in this paperwork and that
the rest of the claims that are based
off those assumptions would be subject
to the inaccuracy as well
further discussion
Marion Clark would you please call the
role
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leckis no
representative Ford
no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative Corey Taylor no
representative Miler yes
representative Lane yes representative
Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
we have a again a no recommendation
foreign
motion on the floor ought to pass I'm
429 with without an amendment as as
introduced
okay
go ahead
Vice chairman cordelli no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford
no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Peter now no
representative Corey tiello no
representative Eiler
yeah
representative Cornell I'm sorry yes
hold on
um okay
yes
representative Blaine
okay just one for the record I want to
make sure okay representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
10 years 10 knees
so who's running the minority or the one
side the
OTP side and the itl
and the iql representative Drive where
you're going to write the uh
I mean there wasn't a there was an
emotion or a second name right
foreign
OTP
you can offer a floor Amendment but
there's no otpa but here because that
was not approved the other one which we
had it was approved remember eleven nine
so this one was not approved so it would
have to be a floor Amendment and the OTP
he can speak to what occurred during the
meeting and saying yes and yeah these
are the three areas which we're
recommending that change right
but um well like like when when we um
let's say a
emotion
with I mean let's say there was a
majority report in minority and The
Minority Report could be an otpa
position even though there was no
amendment that passed on it
that happens all the time yes yes it
does so so this would be a a no
recommendation
foreign
I should have the reports by the end of
Monday
because I want to be able to look them
over and then I want to get them you
know upstairs have them reviewed
upstairs then back down so Lindsay can
get sent to the calendar in mid
Wednesday
and where they are an early Bill we
don't want to mess up on this we want to
we we you don't have to act on that
first which do you're recommending OTP
one person presents another person says
yeah that's great so good I don't need
anything here but then we get into
discussion and through discussion you
can enter an amendment
and
my question is do I need anything here
which one which party the last thing we
did with the OTP the last roll call my
sister I don't have motion or secretary
yeah there was a motion on that the uh
okay well I missed it
yeah wait a minute
the last last
OTP did we have a motion to OTP
ought to pass
yes who made that
um
yeah it's all it's some yeah
that's I thought they did yeah yeah so
we're good we're good with that yeah
we're just trying to make sure it's
we have three today that are going no
yes 626.